in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast well we have
our returning guest ed to of course came
out of hiding once again yes I did you
know what his realizes I'm looking into
the screen got the craziest [ __ ]
t-shirt ten I've ever seen in my life
so before we even talk about that
[ __ ] you and of course we have a very
special guest only because we have been
on this theme of talking about
specifically I mean you guys know what's
going on in this country and I come from
a very I would say I wouldn't say poor
background but I would say poor very
poor background and it wasn't it wasn't
really an inner city he was still like
in a relative like suburb but it was
like kind of borderline in the area
where I was gonna be either really poor
or not too poor so I kind of wanted that
nice little medium area of that I'm John
what's your last name
kwon jang-ho John Kline you are a vice
principal of an inner city school or
charge school I was at a charter school
but right now I met at a inner-city
school okay so you were um we got the
charter school for nine years
oh damn yeah yeah five years as an
English teacher is a high school for
years as an assistant principal and then
last school year I transitioned over to
my new district uh-huh
what made you want to go into education
in the first place because for me
originally I I wanted to be a teacher
and then I had a conversation with my
dad and then he said oh so you want to
be poor educator I mean so what what
made you want to go into education
specifically and even then you wanted
you went into a charter school yeah to
make a difference not that's not it I
got asked that question like an
interview once then I gave that and this
was like earlier on in my career and
then afterwards some dude who I met kind
of an impression I was like eh you know
we like you would have a spot for you
we'll keep you on tabs but don't ever
give that [ __ ] answer
yeah everybody wants make a difference
don't don't say that you know the truth
yeah it started because in college you
know I didn't really have a clear idea
of what I wanted to do you know ends
like my profession and I reached out to
my sister because I started off with a
busy con major thinking I'll go into
like finance or accounting something
stable it's like every other Asian yeah
yeah like you steer away from the lawyer
whatever like doctor route and there's
like no I just want to make money but I
talked to my sister who was out in New
York and I was taking some finance
classes and I was telling her like hey
do not like this is just beating me up
like I have no motivation to study I
didn't have that much motivation to
study anyway but it was like compounding
it and making it worse and so I was
asking like hey does it get better like
into operatives like just get more like
interesting it's just not gets worse if
you can't do it right now like I hate my
life right now so I recommend that you
get out so I was like alright so I got
out and I was thinking like okay well
can I switch to and I always grew up
loving reading that's just something
that like my mom and dad really
instilled in me like my summer school
daycare was my parents just cuz they
both worked they would drop my sister
knock me off you know what the library
and it's like alright start at this end
and just work your way down yeah so I
became an English major and I started
liking philosophy so minor than that and
I thought I'd you know think that are
like okay what can I do so I talked to
like one of those guidance counsellors
like what are some careers that an
English major can do because it kept
hearing that English majors you just
become poor you know English major and
philosophy would be helpful for law
school if that's something that you want
to consider so I actually interned or
not intern because it was paid but it
was like somewhat of a roll between
being an intern and a gofer you know at
a law firm at a creme de firm and it was
pretty small but I did that and I
started like one of my responsibilities
were to listen to interviews and then
transcribe them and then do some
research and see like what are some like
relevant cases with ed law but I was
reading some of these transcripts I was
like yo this dude is like
clearly guilty why or why are we
defending him or like what's the case
can it be built on and I remember the
lead lawyer or attorney at the time was
like we're not here to interpret like
guilt or innocence
we're just interpreting the law for them
you know whatever the case is this
person who may look guilty still
deserves like a fair trial due process
and should deserve like the best
opportunity that he can get with the law
that we interpret and that just didn't
sit well with me you know my core values
so I got in like it just happened by
chance I got invited to go volunteer at
a youth group like summer camp and it's
something that I used to like
participate in but it was like an old
mentor of mine like a young I was like
eh like what are you doing this summer
we need some extra hands
you want to come out and I was like no
it's not really my thing I kind of like
you know moved away from the church he's
like now you don't have to do like any
prayer or spiritual stuff we just need
you like in the kitchen I can do that
and it's like I could reconnect with
someone like the old church homies and I
realized at that trip and I think it was
really transformative because I
interacted with like used in a way that
just invigorated my soul you know like
it just energized me in a way that I was
like I like this what can I do more with
this I don't want to like be a priest I
don't want to like like the opportunity
of teaching so I started volunteering at
some schools seems like this is
something that I want to do but it was
really the the kids who attracted me
like there's something about it that was
like authentic and honest that I didn't
find like at a creme de firm especially
and it seemed fun at that time I didn't
know how like shitty they got paid but
yeah that's how I started oh that's
crazy I mean what can you explain to
people what exactly a charter school is
I live next to a charter school back in
Sacramento so I know what it is
charter school you're from Sacramento
yes yeah a charter school in a nutshell
is a school that has opened up with the
permission that was given a charter like
a contract by the local district to
exist because the charter school finds
like some niche or an area where they
feel like they can do they can
outperform the neighborhood school yeah
so whether that comes from instruction
or providing some specific programming
like Fine Arts or they they provide like
just a different experience and it could
happen because there's over crowdedness
in schools we could also happen just
because an outside organization sees
like like an under performance and says
hey we think we can open up a school and
actually outperform the local schools oh
wow so our charter schools are privately
funded or its publicly funded both
there's like mixed models some charter
schools have a lot more private funding
so they just have like grants and donors
yeah and different like foundations that
help like support them but there are
some schools that exist just on the
public dollar hmm and then you went from
the charter school into what you do now
which is yeah but but charter schools
tend to still be in inner cities not
necessarily not necessarily some charter
schools have been opening up like in you
know predominantly affluent areas huh
Huntington Beach or because they're
providing like a niche program okay well
maybe there's you know a segment of that
city that's not doing as well as
everyone else in that yeah so they come
in yeah well what do you think like just
off top your head the ratio would be
then to like affluent neighborhoods to
you know more I guess poor socio not
economic it is more for sure and
underprivileged areas yeah yeah
so was it charter school built around
that area to give these kids like a leg
up is that what it is
in one sense yeah yeah yeah because um I
mean this is so interesting because I
when it comes to like education because
for me I didn't give a [ __ ] about
education I could give two [ __ ] shits
less about in high school like I
literally I'm I wasn't better this
[ __ ] but I it was hard for me to
see value in it be even if my parents
harped it on me right like it's just I
was a lot younger my parents like you
have to get into a college you have to
get into a college it's important it's
important it's important
think when I hung around certain peers
they didn't give a [ __ ] about an
education I didn't give a [ __ ] either
yeah and you know that that really would
beg the question then right like in in
like a poor socio-economic area how do
you get kids to care about education
when what's around them is not focused
on education right exactly it might it
might be like drug dealing right it
might be gang banging right so like in
that sense then how do you get kids to
care right yeah I mean I think that's uh
there's no I mean I don't have first of
all I don't have an answer to that
question right I'm not an expert in that
field and I would really question anyone
who says oh this is the answer to get
unmotivated kids motivated I think for
anyone how do you motivate them is there
there was a lot of like research and
theories built on it but to actually
apply it to different like specific
groups it's it's really hard to define
but I think when you you ask a question
of like okay we're in inner-city schools
there may be an assumption that there's
less motivated kids and so how do you
remote of eight them that question in
itself may be biased right mmm cuz
you're coming at it from like an assumed
land right right right and then I think
it's also problematic because then you
just put the onus completely on the
students and say this is your
responsibility to be more motivated to
be more successful and you know invested
in your future and I think if you polled
anyone they'd say hey do you care about
your future most of them would say for
the day yeah it's rare even if someone
vocalizes that you know I just find it
hard to believe it just goes against our
like self-preservation you know hmm so I
think the better question then is what
is going on at that school that is
unmotivated I mean what is your
educational experience right now that
you devalue you know will they have
enough funding right right do you have
enough funding like okay so what are you
interested in yeah you you want to study
more of you know current events in your
history class but you're reading about
old dead white guys right no or you want
a better sports program or you want you
know debate or you want better like
extracurricular programs like dances and
clubs but there's just no room for it no
yeah
because I feel like the after-school
program aspect is the part that gets
kids really into school
right I think like at the school
programs first of all for poor kids it's
very very important because they need a
place to go yeah if there's like a lot
of people who are like in terrible like
socio-economic situations there's no
babysitter there's no person waiting for
them at home right yeah so to get them
out of troubles to give them an activity
right you don't want them on the streets
yeah on their free time right you want
them involved and in like a community
that kind of cultivates positivity and
learning right whether it's a sports
team or you know pursuing I guess like
those extra extracurricular subjects
right that that aren't part of the
regular curriculum right yeah yeah cuz
Whitney Whitney had a lot of money right
I mean I don't know exactly what I've
never looked at their their books it's
publicly yeah well yeah it's a public
school yeah yeah it's all available yeah
there's something called like the local
control funding formula and like I mean
like if their money's available you
could see their books and like their
plans because when it comes to funding
right like it's it's so odd because when
I when I compare my high school
experience to other people's right and I
hear the the courses that they're taking
in high school I didn't have any of that
[ __ ] they're like oh like we're like
certain art programs that you could take
as an elective class right like we had
like shop like woodwork here I didn't
have shopper woodwork oh do you guys
yeah we didn't have anything like that
that and it's like some schools and
districts still have it so my current
district has things like that and
categorized under CTE what's this like
career technical education schools in
our district may have had it like
Artesia bar and so it's really a pathway
where it's like okay I'm not headed
maybe towards the traditional four-year
university or even like you know
Community College and then call a
university but I want to go straight
into a trade school so let me build the
CT skills like shop or woodwork or I
mean there's other things now too that
taps into there's like forensic science
I mean there's things I could go across
like the stem whatever type of classes
hmm yeah cuz we had I like I just wonder
named Jared I remember him like he he
was in shop class all the [ __ ] time
and lo behold he's a grease monkey now
like that's what he does for a living I
feel like a lot of students they kind of
knew their lane like they sucked at
every [ __ ] class like they were just
dumb as [ __ ] yeah but when it came to
shot this [ __ ] could build
anything right so I remember like he had
like this old Toyota Tacoma and the next
thing you know that should look like it
was gonna like go over rocks and you
know buildings and climbs over [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] did he do this but you just
want how to do that without his lane I
mean and luckily he'd there was a lane
for him to pursue but like what you're
saying is that sometimes that Lane isn't
there for the kids to actually even have
a chance to pursue it right yeah and by
the time that you know you're kind of
reaching graduation age it's already too
late because you've already have like
completely lost interest in education at
that point yeah right exactly yeah well
the last because the last time we were
here we were talking about specifically
because in your position like you're
you're a vice principal of a school
right yeah because we were talking about
the situation in Witney where which was
your alma mater as well right how
there's a lot of like anti-blackness in
that school right yes sir and we you
know reading a couple of these emails
that these students were sending to me
it's very interesting how in that school
specifically both of them talked about
not the students but they also talked
about the teachers and how they
perpetuate that specific thing that you
know it bleeds into the students right
so for my thing like I always wonder ok
number one why is it not addressed
number two why how does it get addressed
and number three huh does it become a
big enough issue where it should stop
right because if the educators don't
find it to be a problem they're the one
perpetuating that type of stuff like
word where does where does who can step
in to change that in that school because
I didn't go with that like I always
mention I never grew up with that and
then everybody minded that would be a
huge issue but when I see that in
another school such as Whitney which you
know lo and behold when I was
researching and I found out it's like a
highly accredited school and you would
think that at a place in an education
level that high it wouldn't be a problem
like that especially in a school quote
unquote no they're not black they are
colored people right their agent
majority them are Asian so where does
where does administration's
responsibility step in and how does that
change yeah I think that's a good
question and you know what's funny is I
saw something that this morning I
haven't fully like read it or processed
it but there was like a petition request
that came out in like that Facebook
group Facebook group and in it they some
we're like a group of authors they wrote
like this manifesto or like not a
manifesto but requests on like how they
can see change and I thought the
recommended
there were pretty solid and they're a
really good starting point so I skimmed
through it I mean like I spent a total
of maybe like two minutes on it but
something's that resonated with me was
like first of all creating like a zero
tolerance policy right and I think
something that's related to that is as
educators we are mandated reporters what
that means is like two quick examples is
anything that's related to like sexual
harassment we have to report otherwise
were held accountable and responsible
like if if a student comes to me and
says hey like event a may have happened
and I don't know how I feel about I say
hey you know what sometimes it's cool
don't worry about if I said something
like that I would lose my credential or
potentially lose my credential or be
even be locked up if I came out later on
that reported it to him and he never did
anything
same thing for neglect or abuse you know
even if you observe something so for
example if like a student just comes in
with the same pair of jeans and it's
tattered or two weeks later I see like
the same food stains and something's
gonna you know just catch my attention
now it's like hey maybe like what's
going on like a are those like your
favorite pair of jeans like no well you
know what my mom hasn't been home in
like a couple weeks or my washer broke
down and I actually you know just I
don't know like I'm getting hungry or
whatever the case if I hear these things
I have to report it to ya to child
services but um so going back to that
what's going on at Whitney they brought
up something called zero tolerance and I
don't think that's what they're exactly
alluding to but I think we're heading
closer in that direction if we say we
will not tolerate like racism whether is
is that something that like needs to be
instated like from an as an educator
shouldn't that already be a given and
stand the fact that it has to be
introduced yes we're gonna have zero
policy from now on
it sounds a little ridiculous right it
does but then like if it's not written
down or Amala see then there's nothing
that really like govern yeah yeah yeah
so like fighting B and then this is like
controversial and I don't necessarily
agree agree with like a zero tolerance
for fighting but
just as an example of zero tolerance
fighting was introduced as that so
anytime it happened then there was
action you know whereas before I was
like well was it really a fight you know
so there's a problematic okay he's doubt
but I remember seeing that I saw like
really developing some cultural
awareness or having black champions on
campus who are adults right like an
advisor you know we had like counselors
or advisors mama Logan yeah yeah you
know are having a diversity equity like
inclusion trainings for for students I
mean I mean for staff but also creating
curriculum for students so I remember
those things and I think that's like
really heading in the right direction
providing space for for black culture to
be celebrated to be recognized not just
when like issues come out but
consistently saying like hey these were
or this is a marginalized group let's
elevate them let's de marginalize them
because we know what the dominant
culture is yeah not only is it white but
at Whitney it's it's yellow it's Asian
modulus right yeah it is modulus and so
I could see how just raising awareness
saying I mean like the first steps of I
don't know if this is like part of a a
or whatever it is but of recognize like
recognizing a problem is the first step
and saying we want to do something about
it from like decision makers it's
incredibly powerful
you know if it happens behind closed
doors then as an administrator sometimes
we have to deal with sensitive issues
and I'm talking about maybe like a
parent who comes in who doesn't agree
with like our policy so for example we
had a lot of kids bringing in alcohol
and hiding it in bottles and just as a
stopgap to stop it immediately we said
no outside drinks for tiny and try
strategize because it was happening too
much where we couldn't get ahead of it
and then some parents came in and my kid
wants to drink what's the working right
now it gets hot you know yeah
and so pairs to come in is like hey my
kid's gonna get dehydrated and he
doesn't like the water device like at
the fountains is there a way you can
make an exception so we created some
backdoor rules like okay we'll create a
list if we get parent permission and
you're monitoring what the student is
bringing in will allow it you know but
we didn't add
vert eyes that yeah cuz as soon as you
put it on paper people are gonna hold
you right no everyone's gonna yeah my
office would have been filled yeah just
get a work look added workload on top of
everything else you got going on yeah so
I think what they're doing is really
cool because we kind of talked about it
before but these are peers you know
these are like our mid 30 year old I
want to say you know students but
they're not they're full-grown adults
who something was like I have an
investment in Whitney and I'm gonna do
something and that's pretty cool yeah I
mean but the thing is to now some of
these people are educators some of these
people are lawyers right so they're kind
of looking at it and wrecking well
obviously there's the personal
attachment because that's that's a
school that they actually went to but
then also hearing about it just from
like objective objectively speaking like
what the hell is going on there right
like we need to do something because we
have the power and the experience now to
do it yeah it's not it's not something
we're just like well that sucks but what
can we do
Yeah right I think the sad thing is like
for when I look at an institution like
that right and it's sad for me because I
always think now and I'm only starting
to believe this more and more now is
that it seems that punitive measures are
the things that really motivates people
or maybe not so much more but scares
them if [ __ ] starts to scare them
because a lot of people like let's say
even Whitney like I don't know what the
school is like yeah but I could see
educators who are in that area that
doesn't they don't want like the
negative media to come in they might do
the lip service of saying of course
we'll get to it
so like for me I would like to see if if
some in a school like that for them the
thing about hiring new educators who are
of color that do understand this right
because you could go ahead and put
somebody in that school and say let's
say for seven like it like me I become a
teacher right and I'm gonna teach these
kids about like black American Studies
it's like it's not the same you know
this is like secondhand information you
know so for in that type of case to like
you have education you could tell them
like hey this is what you have to do
they go okay but that doesn't really
change do they really care like for
example you know recently you know
Khalif you leave Cleef has been trying
to rate uh they have a group that called
like ybs right young black scholars and
so they went to go ahead and donate
money and when they went there he told
me that they said that
he goes well here's the money for for
ybs and they were like let's ybs it's
like what do you mean with ybs this
young black scholar so go okay well let
me go check to see what that is yeah so
for me i see that so it's a lot of lip
service you know so because they could
go ahead and tell the public all will do
better but there's only about like four
or five black students and it really
depends on those young students to
really speak up against to see what's
gonna happen but when they are the
minority in a majority how hard is it
for these kids to speak up right so
that's where there has to be well I
don't know what that solution is just
like it seems like it's gonna be a
cyclical issue where they constantly go
okay where we had this group called ybs
and then the whole public goes oh young
black scholars they got it done but as
it goes to show when Khalif went over
there here's the money for YBS what's
that what's the next step do you have to
get [ __ ] flamed like what what are
these people gonna do yeah that is
tricky to write because like there are
certain people in the administration who
are accused of you know having some
racist comments or racist behavior and
so question is do those people get
replaced or do you give them a second
chance with these new policies and
stated like the zero-tolerance policy
right I mean because if these people is
either grown adults right whose
worldviews are I mean I'm not gonna say
set in stone but it's shaped pretty well
at that point in their life yeah and if
they have these type of views and if
they have these type of thoughts and
they've acted on that to students I mean
that shows huge amount of negligence and
irresponsibility to be in a position to
educate the future you know so I mean
what's your thoughts on something like
that yeah I think um they're valid
firstly what he was bringing up was
about like the how effective like
punitive measures can be and I think
what you're also kind of bringing up or
like you guys are transitioning to is
like well you have these adults who
don't know better and they obviously
didn't do better so how are they going
to be changed now when they're like you
know twenty thirty years into the game
and I think people can't change but I
think if you kind of remove I mean with
some crimes or offenses or behaviors
it's the the consequence has to match
that right you're the consequence has to
match the crime but I think when it
comes to like you know insensitive
remarks racist you know like just
stereotypes that you perpetuate or
literally just offensive marks and
actions I think if you separate that
behavior from the person and say hey
this is why it's offensive this is why
we can't say this here's another way to
go about it here's a train here's the
impact that it has here's a historical
context why this is important to
consider when you're teaching or when
you're counseling or whatever the case
is then I think if people have the
opportunity to respond and then if they
don't then I agree with you I said
removal find someone else
yeah like diversify the staff right or
incentivize it maybe the whole area is
so homogeneous that only a certain type
of you know educators are trying I think
there's ways to incentivize it with
either pay or you get to start this
program or whatever the case is right
yeah for example like there was a letter
that we read and there was a couple
letters that I read and they were
talking about certain teachers
pinpointing them out cuz they're the
black student and this is what they felt
I mean obviously this isn't this is
facts based on what he or she said yeah
and you know it's secondhand exactly you
know and he said that you know what
teacher called me autistic you know like
what the [ __ ] and he was like yo like I
did well in this class but whenever I
would speak up I'll raise my hand I
never ever got picked once throughout
the whole year to when I'm raising my
hand to answer or if I did get something
right there would be a backhand remark
like oh you got one right you know yes
you're not so autistic after these
backhanded comments you know and so it's
it's like you know what where does where
does that come into play like how does
if a student spoke up and said like hey
this teacher did this this and this to
me like what what happens then yeah I
think I'm if you start change because
change is just so daunting you know but
if you start small and they went back to
the zero-tolerance type of thing or
whatever it I mean I admit I should stop
saying zero-tolerance I have like a
personal you know opinion about zero
tolerance yeah but that's just you know
went back to that idea of really not
tolerating and putting it down on paper
and saying like okay teachers like we
are not going to tolerate this kind of
behavior or worse in the classroom and
students we're gonna empower you to hold
your teachers accountable and to monitor
that and report it if it happens and so
we're gonna document this and if we
start noticing a pattern or a history of
these behaviors here like the very clear
next steps that's gonna happen you're
gonna be forced to do training you're
gonna have to you know figure out big do
better or be let go and I think if you
start a process like that you put it on
paper I think that's one way that change
can start and you can start building
momentum along with other things that we
talked about so it looks like here mr.
Johnson has the fifth report that he's
being a [ __ ] do teachers go through
like sensitivity training in terms of
like you know different cultures and
ethnicities do they do they have a
mandatory type of training system for
them in place I'd say I mean in my
experience which is still pretty narrow
and once again I'm not an expert you
know I will say that it's not mandatory
like sexual harassment training right
but and it varies across districts
across schools even across you know just
States or whatever the case is because
there was this shift in education where
it's like less top-down like being
directed when you do because there's
like this creative element of teaching
yeah you have to inspire and you have to
play something it's your own right and
fire others and so they realized telling
people what to do wasn't effective
because first of all it's just not gonna
get done humor sometimes as a converse
effect where people being told what to
do they want to do otherwise and so if
this [ __ ] training then people
can take that and kind of like turn it
into something that's their own but to
your original question is that training
provided like widely let's say no mm-hmm
I think that's problematic too I think
that's something that should be
standardized right because we talked
about this man like I had no idea
obviously I'm learning all this stuff as
we go because of the current events but
just how many hours cops are trained
versus you know and they
to comparison to how long a barber is
trained and a barbers trained like four
times the amount in terms of hours they
put in before they have to be allowed to
cut people's hair on their own yeah
compared to a cop so like these are the
things that always concern me because I
don't know this from from my end right
so I just assume for some reason I
assume that Oh teachers go through
sensitivity training because this is
stuff that they should know right
because I think that when we leave
things up to assumption that's when
issues issues come into play right like
I assume this teachers not going to be
racist so I should let them know or say
racial undertones right for example like
you shouldn't say stuff like to into a
young black girls like hey you know like
can I touch your hair you know but to be
honest with you a lot of people don't
know that like for example my fiancee I
had to let her know like when she first
met Khalif she was like say oh can I
touch your hair and that's like a that's
a no-no
she was like why and it was very
innocent it wasn't like no right
nobody was angry or like I don't let her
know it's like first of all it's odd
it's like if somebody came up to you and
say let me run my fingers through your
hair yeah it's very odd for you is
something different but because you're
the norm you don't see it that way yeah
so those are the stuff that I feel like
should be put into place not only not
because like they're so quote-unquote
racist or racially insensitive on
purpose they don't know it's ignorant
yeah for a culture that they don't
understand they wouldn't know right it's
like if somebody came to my house and
they've never met an Asian person and
they walked in with their shoes I'm not
gonna sock him in the [ __ ] face no
you know over here dropping Elvis you
know this podcast is brought to you by
thrive if you want high quality organic
and non-gmo foods delivered to your door
thrive market is the one for you you're
still going to the grocery store why
waste your time I know for a fact that
you wander around aimlessly looking for
the same stuff that for some reason it's
always in a different aisle every time
you go I know because that's not you
that's me
so get thrive I'm serious look a couple
of cool things about being a thrive
member you will save 25 to 50% off
traditional retail prices and their
shipping is free on orders over 49 bucks
I don't know about you but when I go
shopping I definitely spend over 40
million dollars every time so I love
good deals and food that I can trust and
it just makes you know markets very what
you could just walk in get whatever you
want and not only do they have food they
have pet staples cleaning products and a
whole bunch of other beauty products and
more just like any other market so if
you haven't done groceries delivered to
your door you are missing out and thrive
in my opinion is one of the best to do
it it's convenient great deals and for
me it saves time and that's the most
important part for me try thrive market
and become a member
risk free go to thrive comm slash brain
join today and you'll get up to twenty
dollars in shopping credit toward your
first order that's th our I ve market
calm / brain to start your risk free
membership and get up to twenty dollars
toward your first order that's thrive
market calm / brain maybe there's like a
spread spectrum or like a gamut - right
so you say like okay I'm not racist but
and maybe if someone says why I am
racist you know and so I think there's a
lot in between
ya know you could have had an racist
thought a racist action like an racist
whatever instinct that came out just
because of your experiences and then
once you learn to identify it then it
can be like okay well you're a really
cool and great person that behavior of
like just touching someone's hair let's
just cut that out of of your behavior
and here's why and you're still an
awesome person so to continue being
awesome I think has a different effect
yeah they say hey you're a racist for
doing that so knock it off yeah yeah yes
[Laughter]
speaking about that though so like you
know since you started as an educator
and now you're in a role of a you know
assistant principal like when you were
teaching and you know you're basically
in an environment with a lot of
minorities right how do you check your
own like biases right and in like how do
you also hold yourself accountable from
like maybe the things that you're seeing
or the interactions that you have like
to prevent it from like reinforcing
stereotypes right like what's
it's kind of your checks and balances
when it comes to that or was your checks
and balances when it came to that yeah
I'll say
like this is my 10th year in education
and I'm still making the same mistakes
that I did as year one you know I still
have my bias T's come out mm-hmm I still
make racist comments you know I still
make someone feel less than because of
the color of their skin or how they look
and that this happened as a teacher as a
teacher leader as an administrator and
I'm sure it's probably gonna continue
happening and I got to keep chopping
away at it you know it's never going
away but I think what was really cool
was the training that I received in my
previous place they purposefully said
hey this is a problem we're putting it
on paper we're gonna require and
schedule these trainings from everyone
in the district top to bottom right and
and here's what you're gonna learn from
it and here's the impact that we're
hoping to have when it becomes clear
like that and you have an entire you
know organization that's serving you
know ten thousand plus students things
like 12,000 now or like eleven thousand
whatever the case is that has power you
know and I think that resonated when it
weighted would come back into like my
immediate family or my threshold my
locus of you know influence which was my
dinner table then it extended into like
my homies you know we'd have
conversations and sometimes it didn't
end very well but we still had them
which would have been different if I
never had those trainings and so like we
had trainings that were mandated on or
mandatory but it was really cool because
it was on like identifying your implicit
biases understanding what it means to
work with students of color what our
works with to work with people in
underprivileged areas what's culturally
culturally relevant pedagogy and so
that's like probably like what the [ __ ]
is he talking about right now but the
traditional model of teaching is just a
banking model like you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
let me tell you memorize it and just
repeat it back to me mmm right but
culturally relevant pedagogy is more of
like you are a part of this process
join me what do you need to learn what
are you like so you get to know your
students let's build a community because
we sure research has shown people learn
better and are more motivated when
you're you know with peers when you feel
a sense of belonging
you know let's bring in more dialogue
let's value your opinion and let's move
away from like rote memorization like
truth or false
you know facts will memorize like the 50
states able to draw this map yeah
instead let's look at like the
differences between regions let's apply
some higher order thinking skills like
analysis and line evaluation so I think
there are things to do and I put into
like really quality training that if you
get enough people talking about and
implementing it and so this way this
would also translate into the teachers
you're not like left on an island to do
this by yourself you work with your
peers you talk about what I'm really
passionate about this area I want to
improve this you know and I think that's
where you can make some waves one of my
favorite trainings that I received was
around um I forget the the creator of it
but it came from this organization that
focused around increasing equity and
equity mindedness and so I don't know if
you're familiar with that term equity
but it's different from equality equity
is so equal would be fairness means
everyone gets the same thing right
equity means everyone gets what they
need to be successful even if some
people get less or more right but it's
different from like socialism it's just
understanding that we're there are
differences but let's honor those
differences as we like move forward and
so what that looked like specifically
was there's something called this threat
training and it's very like brain based
like neuroscience were once a person
feels threatened by something they
automatically their amygdala like sends
out this chemical response and so your
brain has this response where it's like
okay by Michael I exactly am I am I
gonna fly yeah or they say fight flight
or freeze freeze or appease yeah yeah
right and and you can't control it so by
that dick out Woody's
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
fight or flight
oh yeah my favorite training I didn't
deal with these these social experiences
when you feel threatened and and part of
the training was let's just identify
them let's label them give them a name
and they give you some coping skills on
what to do when these things come about
and some of those is called the scarf
model it was like when you feel
threatened what is being threatened
during this social interaction is it my
curse I forgot what the acronym means
for a psyche what there's autonomy
relatedness fairness oh yeah
certainty and status I kind of went
around by the a status certain day and
going so forth do I feel like my
position in this like social hierarchy
is being threatened that you do not see
me as an authoritative figure or even
when we're among peers I get clowned on
you know like my threat is I feel like a
[ __ ] right now
yeah ya know or like with with certainty
it's like oh I you know what what you're
saying right now is like really
confusing I don't know what's going on
and that's a threat you are threatening
Who I am
like we're no longer like hunters and
gatherers we don't have like like
predators hurting us but we have all
these internal battles of like self
doubt and like insecurities right mmm
and so like autonomy is like don't tell
me what to do like relatedness like I
don't know the [ __ ] you're talking about
you drink a different kool-aid I don't
care about you we do not see eye to eye
you know more like fairness it's like
you know what that person got to do it
so I can do the same and [ __ ] you
because why are you calling me I'll call
him out these are at me these aren't
like comprehensive but there's just a
way to put labels on things
yeah and when I received that training
part of the exercise was like and this
was like over the span of years right it
wasn't like a one-off training it was
like maybe six or seven different
sessions a year
that we revisited but I went back and
thought they were like okay
professionally where did I lose my cool
because my my
amygdala response going back to like my
pops or my appraising is I fight yeah I
get angry and I want to fight back
and during those times it was always
when either my autonomy was questioned
or a lot of my relatedness like I have
to connect with people we have to see
eye to eye and don't tell me what the
[ __ ] to do
yeah but I still want to see eye to eye
with you yeah it's like those kind of
things and I started noticing a pattern
or a trend and you know it really
changed the way I approach things was
that was that very necessary of
specifically working in an inner-city
school just because inner-city schools
are [ __ ] rough dude like there's
they're [ __ ] rough and I feel like
you know that how hard is it to balance
like an authoritative figure but not so
harsh where they look at you like the
enemy mixed in with like you know a
little bit of that being cool and shield
I mean that's a lo-- [ __ ] heart also
also the fact that he stands out just
because of his skin color right so it's
like almost having a double
responsibility of you need to be
culturally sensitive but you also need
to teach them how to be culturally
sensitive the other way around - it's a
two-way street that you need to teach
yeah right 100% I remember going back to
like me standing out because I started
off my my student teaching a Crenshaw
it's a pretty famous there's a pretty
historic inner-city school in like the
heart of LA or like Crenshaw and I
walked it this is like my first week of
student teaching and I didn't bring
lunch yeah when Tao and I went to a fish
drop I love fried fish yeah we grew up
on it because some of our friends used
to work at this fried fish drop Asian
[ __ ] place yeah kind of just like fried
catfish yeah yeah yeah the fish stores
the hair liquor store I mean like yeah
it just fits our profile but I walked in
and and this one particularly had like a
seating area literally everyone kind of
just talked
they they just stopped eating you like
you could almost hear this like ding
ding I was like oh [ __ ] right coming to
the wrong place and they didn't stop
looking
like normally like if something happens
and will continue their business but
they stared at me the whole way and
right there I was like [ __ ] I don't
belong but I need some fish yeah so I
went out ordered I asked for like extra
hot sauce and I actually saw some like
heads nod and it's like okay that was
like an interesting experience but it
always stood out to me because I was
such an outsider but something like some
commonality like brought me like some
head nods know what that meant exactly
their place like this right he knows but
I was always an outsider and even in my
own school where I spent like nine years
I was the only Korean administrator yeah
and then it was like okay let me take
that back and like how many Korean
teachers were there and there weren't
many there weren't even in many Asian
males for a lot more Asian females it's
a predominantly female driven you know
filled feel yeah but still it just
brings me to think like oh [ __ ] I'm an
outsider among outsiders yeah yes adds
another layer but yeah and and and that
makes it extra difficult because one not
only are you an outsider just because
your ethnicity but - because in order
for them to start trusting like an
authoritative figure right I mean
because my guess is actually you told me
about this I mean I I don't know what
the actual percentage is but you said
there's a pretty high turnover rate in
inner-city schools right usually one
year right and then they're like this is
too hard I'm done I don't want I don't
want to be a part of this right I don't
know about the number of years oh it's
definitely the turnover is a lot higher
yeah yeah so let's just say generally
high turnover rate yeah so you have some
of these kids who might be coming from
broken homes who don't really have that
adult figure that brings them security
and like teaches them and it's somebody
that could depend on and rely on and
then you kind of transition into like
the school system where the teachers are
supposed to be playing that role its
facilitators but then if they're seeing
teachers coming in and out all the time
it's like what the [ __ ] is even the
point of me trying to like build a
relationship with this person they're
not even going to be here you know
they're not even going to care
enough to stay or to care about me so
[ __ ] this person and [ __ ] education
right yeah yeah the the the word that
really resonates with me is when you
bring up care how do I demonstrate care
and then I think there's a precursor to
that question as do I really care
you know like authentically looking
right you have to genuinely like ask
yourself yeah do I wanna hear like on
what level of care do I have you know am
I gonna donate all the time and money I
haven't realistically probably no you
know you're gonna burn out yeah and I
think that's kind of like the
expectation that some people see
especially beginning educators when they
go into teaching like oh I can't carry
enough I don't have the capacity for
it's like okay well what level of care
can you provide okay let's let's just
work on that I'm not asking you to stay
until 7:00 p.m. you know every night or
donate half your paycheck because you
see some kids who have less than you you
know like let's think about what care
can you provide and I think when you
start thinking about it that way there
there's a whole slew of things where you
could demonstrate care you know I think
it and then what you're saying is how do
you become effective in the classroom
and countless you know just never-ending
research always says doesn't matter how
much you know until they know how much
you care right it's just like you have
to build relation is the most important
thing you have to develop that human
human relationship first but when you
have so many barriers in between that to
overcome it almost sounds like kind of
never-ending in your beginning journey
to kind of chip away at that and it
sounds like the turnover rate is so high
because they just burn out from trying
to chip away at that yeah it's like
there's no point to this
my heart might have been in the right
place but ultimately so this seems very
hard cuz I don't know what that answer
to that solution is right because I
think like because of the whole you know
a lot of people are starting to think
about this now because of the whole
black life black lives matter movement
yeah so a lot of these inner-city school
does have a huge like black population
Latino and even Asian population right
and so with with in these specific areas
it's like it's hard for me to see how do
you get this to be important to them and
not name is so much to the students I
think is more to the parents right
especially because like on a when you're
[ __ ] poor and this is what people
have to realize to you when you're
[ __ ] poor there's so many things you
have to worry about
right especially when it comes to like
raising your kids most of the times is
does this kid have food this is Kevin
electricity and a roof over their head
so when it comes to that education
process that becomes like lists like
number 10 out of the whole list right
and I think that's the part where I'm
trying to figure out you know especially
from like an educators perspective it's
like how where's that solution right
like how do you how do you take them
from that and say hey like where can we
alleviate something for them along this
process that allows them to put
education first what they do what their
education is completely up to them
because even for me in the when we were
poor right but my parents made it an
important part of my life to distress
education even if they didn't know how
to get it done right I didn't know
anything about your ass yeah or whatever
I think I got very lucky in the sense of
number one like I just I hung around you
know nicer kids in high school later on
and they were a lot more geeky and
dweeby which kind of you know [ __ ] would
like it made more sense for me and so
and I just happen to like reading books
a lot so that helped me out but when it
came to you know grades oh I was trash
you know it was like I had a 2.6 GPA
it was barely I barely got into UCR and
you see I was just accepting everybody
to UC Merced I didn't apply I graduated
Oh 5 ok ok I didn't like my first open
that's the first year they opened there
like you got it I was like to wear UC
Merced and the Sacramento State
University they're like you got in I
didn't apply what the [ __ ] are these
people talking about
I ended up going to Riverside anyways
which was a terrible school at the time
yeah I think once again like I want to
add the disclaimer I'm not the expert
yeah that's like well versed and so what
I what I see or what I what I want to
bring up is just like things that I
haven't you scratch the surface level on
or have to you know just experienced a
little bit but I think when you bring up
like how do you solve that right and I
think it becomes less of a well this
student doesn't care and one of my
triggers is they don't care enough
saying that that's [ __ ] because it's
your job as an educator to design an
experience or an environment where they
will start to care you know one of those
like if you build it they will come
I can't get in contact with the parents
the parents don't care it's like that's
[ __ ] too right because then you
could design an environment or
experience where parents can have like
you were saying especially in low-income
areas the capacity to care and so I
think there was something that I started
learning about like maslov's hierarchy
Maslow's hierarchy of needs like you
can't care about your social or like
emotional health and if you can't eat if
you don't have shelter exactly and so I
think that's where the systemic
oppression the institutionalized
oppression comes in because you have
these marginalized communities with low
access to health care to you know to to
quality foods there's like food deserts
like yo where I was working is like I
tried I think I forgot I didn't grocery
shop so I was trying to just go to a
grocery store to pick up Sunday night I
went to the produce section and it was
just around the block you know I went to
the produce section and like half the
foods the fruits were rotten they
transitioning something new yeah and
then I found I was like oh we just get
like last dibs we kind of get the bottom
of the barrel because the stereotype is
that people in the hood they don't eat
vegetables that's [ __ ] crazy
and you know why so the next day I went
into my classroom was like would you
guys have for dinner would you guys have
for dinner Burger King or I had fried
you know veggies or when I was I did
anyone have a salad no so normal spawn
with this it was like Oh salad it's
gross what does they have like ranch
right you know so that kind of thing
we're like that's foods cheap right I
mean
it's cheaper or faster yeah easier like
access to high quality you know paying
job yeah or they don't have access to
not only like health care like physical
healthcare but yeah yeah you know social
healthcare and so I think if you start
building those infrastructures like what
Minneapolis is like proposing to do in
theory I feel I will see some results in
like five years where it's like okay
we're gonna see decreased crime yeah cuz
people won't have to dare they're happy
you know they're thriving we're gonna
see an increase of diversity in the
workplace I mean this is just ideal but
it also depends on how it's gonna be
implemented or executed or like you're
saying like how people are gonna
actually be willing to change yeah how
do
how do schools get funding cuz I when I
heard was as schools are funded by
whatever the the houses around it dander
dyes testing to write that you guys
gotta hit your marks yeah so it's it's a
complicated really antiquated like
formula that needs reform but property
tax is one of them yes the the majority
of funding comes from property tax so
it's localized and then there's there's
federal funds there's something there
used to be like all these different
categories like if a student was special
education or an English Learner or
whatever their income was this there's
all these different categories but it
really got the those categories shrank
but that's part of it so federal funding
provides money as long as it's used for
that population and then a lot of it is
property tax and then more as that's a
scary thing right it's because I mean
how do you break out of that these are
low income area they're getting is from
the property tax payer how do you better
these schools how do you give them the
tools you know this is why I see it's
it's just so [ __ ] up to me right cuz
you know I used to live in style past
right I remember I walked onto this high
the the South past high school they have
this track outside it's a nice Community
College and they're like this is a high
school I was like the [ __ ] is just a
high school this is not a high school
alright I know this is the high school
and that's when people told me it was
like oh it's the property tax around the
area that pays for this school and
that's why a lot of people they pay
other people to use their address just
to get their kids into this specific
public high school yeah and I was like
damn this is this is such a weird thing
right yeah because I don't see a
solution for that it's like well how do
we get more funny into these schools for
kids who have a thirst for knowledge who
do want to better themselves right do
they also have to pay some money to get
their kids into this other school you
know and it's just such an odd thing for
me to see cuz I had no idea that's how
it worked and then I found on the south
pass like there's like an extra tax that
these homeowners have and that they put
more into the school yeah it's like what
we were talking about with Nick Hill on
the last podcast was like it's it's like
so many things that's all interconnected
and and really I guess like the most
general thing you can look at is the
disparity in wealth right it's just such
a huge gap and so like people in
low-income areas they get priced out of
everything they get priced out of
education
they can't priced out of the justice
system right like there's so many things
and factors against them for them to
thrive and actually be you know like a
contributing member of society in a
healthy and like a growth growing way
but yeah it's it's money at the end of
the day right that that's like really
the decor of a lot of these problems
yeah because covert racism works like
out in the open and it's individualized
like I called this person Michael
Christie yeah I call this person you
know a racist name or derogatory term
that's covert visualised that gets
called out you know in this day of
social media like good luck getting away
with that you know yeah yeah yeah good
luck but oh a covert sorry I meant over
radio that's a covert institutional
racism that's really at the system's
level it's still happening you know and
I'm still learning about this too but
that like that documentary 13th really
brought up there was like actual
campaign strategies that was brought up
during I forget which presidential
campaign is like we can't call them this
anymore
but here's what we'll do to still keep
them down I think part of that is like
like redlining I don't know if you guys
know yeah with a red line neighborhood
this is where you stay
yeah like loans weren't given out to you
know people of color or like hey despite
your income level you're not gonna live
here right or people who try to purchase
homes they put down an offer yeah okay
well let's look at this name let's meet
in person sorry buddy like you're not
coming here so I think like things like
that can be addressed the hard part
about all that stuff though is that no
matter how many times these these facts
are brought up people think its opinion
they go oh well like for example one of
the I saw a video where they were kind
of debunking what this other video was
saying when it was trying to explain
what systemic racism was right and you
know one of the one of the facts that he
brought up he goes well redlining is
illegal it's like that's cool it doesn't
mean it didn't happen
that's what and it's so hard to convince
these people right the fact that he
could make a point four point basis to
what to debunk systemic racism and his
only argument is like it's not supposed
to happen whether it's not supposed to
happen doesn't change the fact that he
[ __ ] did and it still does yeah it's
just it's so hard that's why like when
we
when we had these bln movements right
I'm hearing a lot of the stuff they go
racism doesn't exist anymore they don't
believe it's there because it's not
their reality
and the thing is dirt they're so
insulated in their beliefs and in their
worldviews that they're not ever making
an effort to brag because they don't
need to yeah they're comfortable where
they're at so that develops like a sense
of complacency - yeah I mean I have no
problems and I don't see why these
problems would exist for anybody else
cuz I don't that's not my reality that's
not my issue it's so weird that they can
i mean i'll break it down like this it's
like you can't see that you have like an
implicit bias when it comes to some like
somebody's like color of the color of
their skin when this is what you were
taught to see were you I had KFC I had
food poisoning once and I'm like [ __ ]
KFC like [ __ ] KFC for the rest of my
[ __ ] life right yeah I could do that
with fried chicken you do that with a
person too easy
right if you had this negative construct
of what these people are fed to you your
whole life you are gonna see it that way
yeah and it's like I'm trying to figure
a my approach to changing somebody is to
embarrass the [ __ ] roast the [ __ ]
living [ __ ] out of them it's what it
works for me you know and I understand
some people are like I don't agree with
you and I'm like cool you don't have to
agree with my methodology you can do it
your way and I completely agree that you
should do it with the kind of heart just
like a Jesus the Christ saying you
should do that I want to do that too
right but I try to pretend like a
majority of my life I'm tired of it now
so I'm gonna do it my [ __ ] way
because it's hard to kind of tell
somebody something that they just
refused to see or believe right yeah
yeah something very simple - like when
what's that uh what's uh what's it
called this segregation when the what
1960 what well the Civil Rights Act
happened when in 1965 or something
yeah wasn't that means like if it's like
in the mid-1960s right that means he
would be like in what mid 50s and then
you would still understand what they
were born during time of segregation
right and their people this is how
people equate it they go well during
that time it stopped I was like when has
there ever been a [ __ ] law that
wasn't stated and everybody followed
that rule like every person that
believed that segregation was okay the
law wasn't that
and they go you know what you're right
I'm done with this and they move on we
had covin they said hey put on a mask
everybody and you have to shut your
business down people still open up their
businesses right they didn't walk around
with math dated a social distance so if
it works with something like that what
made you think that was that easy for
people who had like these deep dark this
deep dark hatred towards a specific
group of people for to disappear
overnight
that rooted issue you know yeah the what
you're bringing up kind of makes me
think about the most frustrating defense
that I've come across like in
conversations and this is with like my
love brothers you know even like family
members is hey you know what like I
appreciate where you're coming from
let's I just agreed to disagree like we
can do that right you got to respect my
opinion and we all will agree to
disagree here remember I saw something
online I was like that's cool you know
when you agree to disagree that ketchup
is better for [ __ ] like moral issue
yeah can't just slide this on yeah sure
that's agreed to disagree that I think
these people are oppressed and I think
that they're not yeah that's problematic
or about or even worse that they deserve
to be oppressed or you know or I mean so
yeah that's like the most frustrating
thing is that you can't you can't take a
soft pass on something like this they
get like you said because it's a moral
issue no right it's it's a human rights
issue and it's so like for me my thing
always is whatever that whatever issue
it is that we're talking about let's
always start from a human being
standpoint let's first start it look at
it as a human being no skin color no
background let's start and then from
there we can we can progress the
conversation but let's start at a human
point because if you really are not a
racist then you'll have no problem
treating and objectively that this
person is a human this person is a human
this is what happened let me look at it
from that lens first objectively and
then we'll get into the details right I
think it's even harder when it's like
you know people you you you there in
your tribe right there they're your
peoples they're your family or your your
brothers or your sisters yeah and your
your closest homies and you it's hard to
have these conversations because at the
end of the day it's like okay I
prioritize our friendship you know we we
spend
20-plus years building this I'm not
trying to throw this off the window and
I can't say you know what your moral
compass is just pointing it your
TrueNorth doesn't align with mine so
like Deus is like I'm not gonna have
anything to do with you and I can't
change your opinion mm-hmm so farewell
you know it's more of like okay that
agreed to disagree is it's all right
fine let's do it for the sake of the
friendship and I still love hanging out
with you but when can we have these
conversations and that's something that
I've been grappling with yeah I talked
to actually John Howe about it recently
ya know that I was telling the same
thing that you know who's John Howe he's
a music producer friend but yeah yes so
I'll just you know what we were just
talking about what was going on and I
was telling them like there's people I
know who have drastically different
views on on the subject than I do
you know and if I were to have
conversations with these people it's
gonna hit a stone wall really fast
really quickly but I try to maintain the
friendship - like you said for
opportunities to progress on that front
right to try to chip away on that front
but then his response was like bro at
this point in my life those people I
just cut out like I don't even have the
time or energy for it because he's a new
dad - right
shoutouts to a man yeah so it's like
it's more of like finding what's worth
investing into and then what's not right
and like you said you're grappling with
that now yeah I don't grapple with [ __ ]
straight for conversation like it's
pretty much well I mean I've been like
that since I was super younger so it's
hard not to but it is difficult though
right it's difficult to cuz it's
uncomfortable like that it's like why
even address it if it's gonna make our
friendship weird but I'll get there
don't like without that even being the
intention ya know I mean for me this is
like I just know how I am and everything
comes out of my face so if I disagree
it's already there in my face so I might
as well just say it right there's like
something even really small like if I
don't like somebody like one time I'm
not sure if you were there but there's
somebody that we kind of know in between
that I specifically [ __ ] hate this
guy's gonna like I [ __ ] hate him with
everything that I have like to like the
very deepest part of my ballsack I feel
like your energy
and then it's our it's our buddy like he
came to he came to LA and then we always
go to a certain spot to drink and so
he's coming over and he was like you
know this guy's gonna come and I'm like
you know I [ __ ] hate him right he's
like yeah he's dying laughing he goes I
just try to be nice to him as possible
and the moment he comes in he hugs me
and I'm like you know I don't [ __ ]
like you right and so as we're sitting
down there I'm looking across room I'm
just staring at him yeah hour by hour
buddies like hitting me as I say stop
looking at him I'll stop looking when he
gets the [ __ ] up and go see on the table
dislike that guy so [ __ ] man he's a
[ __ ] leech and I hope you [ __ ] die
but you know like for example I had a
friend to like he's I say he's like a
little bit not even as a joke he's kind
of like on the spectrum a little bit
just enough where he's like a
functioning human in society but it kind
of works toward his case because he's
very emotional akiko work very well
right but he'll say stuff like in jokes
to create shock value so if it's
counterculture to say it he'll say it
because he thinks it's funny as a joke
but he doesn't have the intent to be
racist or be hurtful and anything else
that he does like for example he after
his wife had a had a child this was like
this was like six seven years ago he and
his wife had a child and he comes up and
uh his wife tells me that he called her
fat and I was like okay bro you know and
so I had a conversation with him just
because I know him and I was like hey so
how did you called your wife fat why'd
you do that right he was like what we
had a talk where we said we're going to
be open and honest with each other hey
guy what the [ __ ] you can't do that
because I won't you know we want to keep
ourselves like really open and honest
it's like well I think that you say
stupid [ __ ] all the time do you see me
go out here and could call you stupid
every [ __ ] day like come on man like
you should know better I was like there
are things that you can and can't say
and things that are appropriate she just
had a child move on from it those are
uncomfortable situations like I don't
want to have to have that conversation
with ya but you know when it when it
[ __ ] with like some of my moral
foundations as a human being I think it
actually helps the friendship in the
long run he also was somebody that made
like a fried chicken joke recently right
and he was like well if I if I go out
here and I make a fried chicken joke you
think black people will be mad and it
was dead silent and I was like that's
not funny oh why and I was like look at
the time so I was like also fried
chicken jokes everybody loves fried
chicken is a really old racist joke
don't do it he goes cool got it but you
know he gets a pass because he's a
little on the spectrum if he's willing
to acknowledge that or at least try to
meet halfway of like trying to
understand oh there's a possibility that
I may be wrong here right and now I'm
willing to explore that also for the
sake of the friendship you know but with
some of these people it's a nice life
yeah yeah they're kind of drawing a hard
line you're just pushing your line
further and further in the sand you know
and and and you know what would
basically just at the point John was
making was that I ain't got time for
that [ __ ] in them yeah you know like
history or not friendship be damned like
if our views on these core issues are so
drastic from you know one another then I
really have no point of maintaining a
relationship with you yeah and it's so
it's tricky man it's really tricky
because like some of these people like
you know that they're not inherently bad
people like their intention is I'm gonna
be a [ __ ] racist hate a group of
people you do whatever I can to like you
know make things harder it's just
certain a lot of it has to do with
political political agenda deviation and
and and those views really stem from
that I mean I think that's like the
biggest disparity right now when it
comes to the black lives matter right
you're either extreme right or you're
extreme left it seems like there's no
in-between right now you're being
accused of one or the other
by the by the other side you know if
you're taking a more compassionate
standpoint you're being accused of being
on the extreme left Yeah right if you're
taking a more well I don't really see
that as a problem you're accused of
being on the extreme right so it's like
again going back to the human being
element it's like why the [ __ ] does it
have to automatically be
a political affiliation or political
thing if I have a certain view on it you
know what if I don't identify with a
party and this is how I feel about it
anyway because this [ __ ] person
is a person yeah there's a human being
not about [ __ ] politics man about
life and death about police brutality
about injustice like that's what we're
[ __ ] talking about but constantly and
constantly politics get injected into it
over and over again and that's like the
point where that's the thing that's
really [ __ ] irritating me is that I
want to be able to have these
conversations without the politics
because that's not where I'm coming from
I'm not coming from a standpoint of
politics you know I'm like I said I'm
coming from a standpoint let's talk
about human beings and in justices that
exist and what we can do to make it
better not just for them but for
everybody I mean I think it's hard to
find human beings who are really open
for change right
I'm like that too like when it comes to
specific things that sometimes I just
don't want to hear [ __ ] you know I was
dude I was the fattest [ __ ] person
ever right and I didn't want to hear
that [ __ ] my dad every time I went back
to Sacramento my dad would look at me
and he goes you've gotten really fat I'm
like and I'm like man you know I don't
want to hear that [ __ ] yeah even though
he's like listen I'm worried about your
health and I'm like dude athlete you
know I'm like I'm in denial and we're
having arguments about stuff that's
factually there for me like facts I was
really fat he would hear me breathe he's
like dude like we haven't gone to be so
[ __ ] yeah like we're just eating like
you know like we're just having like
Tony Hawk you know we're just eating
dinner and my dad is like you're
breathing so hard and I'm like getting
angry I'm like breathing hard I'm
breathing hard but you know like I
understand like sometimes we don't want
to see the the the flaw in ourselves
right because I think it makes us
question everything that we did in the
past
and it's a scary thought it's like well
I learned this the most when it comes
when it came to relationships with my
fiancee she would pick things at me that
I didn't like about myself that I knew
was wrong but saying it out loud and
emitting it to her I would rather
[ __ ]
I would rather [ __ ] die not the
toilet seat thing I'm still fighting
about that but like like small things
like for example um what we would get
angry I would that we don't I miss Ben
years this has happened but she made a
rule of hey no matter how angry I make
me made you and even though I'm wrong
and I'm begging you want on you don't
break [ __ ] that's what happened to Milan
breaking his own well not even cos I was
smashing my [ __ ] head
like when we were first together I think
I think in the first two years we're
together i broke for fun cuz there was
nothing I could it was she would always
do when there's a phone in my hand I
would snap that [ __ ] in half and I think
I'd pop used thousands of dollars just
on phones because of her but you know
one of the things that we developed was
like I learned that this was a bad habit
that I had because I saw my parents
fight a lot like I've seen my mom throw
[ __ ] at my dad I seen my dad just chuck
[ __ ] break doors punch balls and so
whenever I would get angry lo and behold
that's how I would solve my anger issues
right so I haven't done that in like
four years or years now but like the
last thing that I threw was this it was
a puff jacket and I she was the most
embarrassing thing I've ever done in my
life I had I remember I cuz we made the
rule like don't so the last thing I
broke was this little cream jar of her
makeup I had even Chuck I just went like
I threw it on the floor and it shattered
and I think it shattered and very more
aggressively than how I threw it so I
didn't think it was an issue but she
starts bawling she goes I told you I
don't like violets and I was like even
throwing like I just just dropped it on
the floor but I was like oh she doesn't
like that type of stuff yeah cuz her dad
used to throw [ __ ] a lot so it's
traumatic for her mmm so we this was
like a year ago or two ago I knew that I
don't throw things anymore but she got
me so [ __ ] mad and you know she was
at fault she even amidst this by his
krump I had a bed this little puff
jacket right I was like it was the most
embarrassing thing I've ever done in my
life and then she starts laughing
racking so I've learned like and you
know I've learned to it's hard it was
hard for me to say hey she goes well
don't break things I think is very funny
if we have kids I don't want our kids to
think about this [ __ ] and my initial
reaction is like well you pissed me off
what else am I supposed to do but that's
not the proper thing to say so
you know I think to when we come from
these places it's not like I'm saying
this to chastise you right because I see
these flaws of myself first before I see
it in somebody else I think that's where
it comes from it's like I'm not saying
like hey recognize your faults and then
be able to open have these open
conversations because it's easy I'm
saying it's difficult I don't know the
most you know no and I think change is
complicated you know and it's a long
journey
yeah everlean year yeah they're like you
grasp regret no like somebody's just
going backwards like no we're changing
right yeah for the worst but it's gonna
get better you know sometimes it's like
that yeah I think what you're bringing
up is like there has to be that love
component and like the actions and it's
like your fiancee I don't know how long
you guys were dating for but and I'm
imagining that it took you know like
some time for for you to progress before
he knows all this talk where we are now
going on almost six years
yes it's August will be six years I am a
long time no it shouldn't like crazy
formative years like in their beginning
adulthood like mid 20s to transitioning
into our 30s you know that's that's
pretty intense yeah she's been around
for a very long time and I think that
was like the probably the biggest lesson
in learning how to change like having
somebody there that you can I can't get
rid of her but like I won't get rid of
yeah and you know recognizing your
personal flaws is it's hard it's so
[ __ ] difficult it's hard to say I'm
sorry it's hard to say you're right
especially when you hate their [ __ ]
guts in the moment right there was like
time to I look and I'm like I actually
hate you
like I [ __ ] hate you but because I'm
wrong I say I'm sorry
yeah and like I used to do this thing
back in there where I mentioned the
podcast like I know I [ __ ] up hella bad
and I just kind of look at the floor
look at me no look at me again I'm like
nom good looking for a corner on the
floor but yeah I think those
uncomfortable conversations are
something that we need to have you know
especially like in school yeah
especially yeah I mean is that hard for
you like if you in your position do you
have to reprimand like teachers at they
well not was a reprimand but have a
conversations with them yeah they're in
school and well
you know what I just realized is you
guys aren't sitting or leaning back on
this pillow we got I got this chair cuz
it look really cool yeah and then I
figured I was way more comfortable
without the actual no but um oh adults
yeah like seriously in schools in
education the kids aren't the problem
it's the adults and it's not the parent
it's not outside factors that so much as
in in you know internal factors and I
think like going through administrative
consequences for teachers and staff is
my least favorite
you know portion of that job and it
sucks cuz you were like we're supposed
to be on the same team if this is
someone who like reports to me or I'm
like their direct supervisor and now all
the the the trainings and tools that I
used in the classroom I still employ
with teachers you know cuz it's still
the same field and it's still relevant
right so I'm prioritizing like
relationships and trainings and being
like their biggest cheerleaders and
advocates but when I have to like
reprimands I want to write them up or
take it up to like you know a couple
different levels
we're like request a transfer or even a
dismissal you know it's it's just it
kills my soul as an educator like I lose
hope literally in like I failed this one
educator we couldn't prevent this from
happening and I'm often seen as I'm
already the bad guy yeah more so than
the the principal because the principal
all the shitty things that they don't
want to do this really I repair right
now and before I was like okay cool like
so what are you gonna do like can I
learn from he's like no you're gonna
step in there just let me know how it
goes alright so that's how it works but
you know it sucks because part of it is
like you know with kids they
the saving grace is always like well
they're young they don't know you know
they can learn they can get better but
when you do it with like a 60 year old
person or like 57 couple years away from
retirement individual it's like damn
yeah there's not much I can do to you
know change this they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah
I'm like just thinking about 30 years of
what you were doing with all these
different groups of kids it's it's
really heavy and it's not something that
I that I enjoy but it's necessary it
must be really awkward like it sure you
as at like a young 30s talking to the 60
year old Matt is like let me talk to you
about your behavior like the the Charter
world tends to have younger educators so
I think I don't know if you asked for us
like how did you get into the Charter
world it's because I graduated from the
teaching program right when the
recession hit so but the worst time the
worst time you know like automatically
like 2030 percent of job sectors just
disappeared
they vanished or anything it may not
have been that much but they even the
positions that they posted they were
just being flown for internal candidates
so like move him around no one was gonna
get hired but there are a lot of these
charter schools in really like tough
areas where they were hiring so that was
my start and I specifically joined a
program that focused on urban ed and so
it was like a seamless transition but
there were cats coming from like the OSI
it's like I did not sign up for this
[ __ ]
I hope it got eaten up yeah and I'm like
I had the same treatment but it was like
at least I had at least a year of
understanding or just learning this is
what you're gonna expect whereas they
thought it was like oh my god they're
gonna love me I love school that's why I
became a teacher you talk about you
don't give a [ __ ] yeah it was like
something that like a student has done
to you before like when you first
started man list man I mean there are
things that the Jackie Chan one that one
was the first like act of defiance or
someone who pushed back Razzak okay this
is pretty funny but this is what I
should expect you know until I can get
better yeah and for me I'm very
performance-based where it's like I want
to keep getting better I gotta outdo my
last performance but it was it was in
class and this kid was just cutting up
and she was just she had so many
opportunities and I'm sure my the class
was chaotic but she was part like just
the most chaotic and so I don't know if
I did this intentionally or not but I
was like I you're [ __ ] out because
you seem like the leader so I gotta make
an example you know and then everyone
else is gonna fall in line and I know if
that's what I really thought in that
split second but looking back on it I
think that's what I did and I said
alright that's it like you know student
you had chances we did this you need to
go you need get out of class yeah it's
just like moving Lang going nowhere like
I don't give a [ __ ] I was like I don't
think you heard me right so I was me
thinking like I'm a thug yeah turned
around I don't think you heard me like
you need to get the F or whatever I said
like out of class and she said alright
then I started walking away thinking
like okay I didn't like say face or yeah
I'm like it's an email to principal
because I might be asked now yeah she
says something it's like Jackie Chan I
was like turn Rollins like did you say
something what'd you say I said Jackie
Chan [ __ ] the rest of like that
class I was just known as mr. Jackie
Chan I could do it consistently reminded
me of that incident where I failed to
act properly to de-escalate yeah you
know what to figure out like why was she
distracted all that thing and maybe she
needed a break maybe she should have you
know gone down to the principal's office
but when she came back the opportunity
to rebuild that was gone it's gone it's
gone because of the way I acted you know
and some people will say like no but
you're taking too much ownership you
know she can't victimize her she
shouldn't be doing that you're
absolutely right but if I start thinking
along those lines what am I gonna
actually change I mean and they're their
standards right you as an adult and as
an educator you have to show restraint
right you can't get baited into like an
emotional response especially when
you're kind of aware of what the
situation is gonna be yeah but the funny
thing is too is like we're humans yeah
it's not robot may yeah stick yeah yeah
I never read I never restored that with
her and she was cooler so at the end at
the end of the year we didn't get along
you know but we like saw eye-to-eye and
we
tolerated each other but after my
training I realized and this happened
after I started receiving receiving some
of those trainings that I alluded to was
I did something similar to another
student a female steward in effect and
then like after that I realized like
female push back is a trigger for me
especially when they like you know get
real like loud or they just like because
I felt you know some of my things were
being threatened but then with her you
know I I didn't cuss at her or anything
but I raised my voice I got really close
to her and then I intimidated like is
there something you want to add no
that's what I thought yeah that's right
and like I walked away or something like
that but like everyone sees that you're
like the class was quiet I had enough
like Capital cultural and social capital
where you know they were able to respond
no one like treating me differently but
you know I felt like [ __ ] afterwards and
so I went to her privately the next day
I pulled her out of like a different
classes a that was totally disrespectful
like I can't believe I did that and
whether you forgive me or not I'm just
gonna like commit to never doing that at
you ever again in person and nobody
should ever do that to you yeah and
that's it with your permission can I
apologize to you in front of the whole
class and she was like that's a little
weird you're just gonna put me on blast
oh yeah well I I got you you know mr.
Cohen like we're cool and then but later
on she came back and said you know I
talked to my parents and said like is
that the first time an adult apologized
to you is like yeah it was like well
having them do it in person and see if
he really means it yeah she didn't tell
me that in person but she came back and
said you know what I actually would like
it in person so I did and I told
everyone then we had like honest
conversations and people were like yo
like mister quandra you're serious like
no one ever apologized to her we're just
kids
yeah but that kind of like then that
became my favorite class yeah the rest
of the year you know what they're doing
things like that like really humanized
Isthmus yeah for sure for sure and it's
holding yourself accountable yeah yeah
I'm so [ __ ] hard cuz I'm cuz I wanted
to be a teacher I would I'd be roasted
like that's what I was doing that's how
I build rapport with them and they would
roast me back and I'm like damn that was
funny let me write that down I gotta
talk to my friends know that kind of
thing there's different ways to build
relationships but um yeah then when you
when you asked like what are some things
that you have seen there are things that
have been disruptive
you know things that have just appalled
me or things that have just broke my
heart because I realized like the
chances of you changing your trajectory
because of like the gangs that you're
involved in or because of yeah yeah it
like there's only so much we can do so
there's something that's popular called
the hundred reps theory it's like you
might get to like the 90th or 99th of
rep and you don't get to see them change
or like really get to that hundred rep
but you're just hoping you planted
enough seeds that it can flourish with
the next educator or the next advocate
or the next person work well there sure
like I literally had thanked part of me
is kind of hesitating because I don't
want to like perpetuate this stereotype
of like inner-city schools but is some
of it's pretty [ __ ] funny too like I
had a male kid who ever I had a policy
of I teach bell-to-bell
no one got to use the restroom when they
were in my class yeah and then it's
illegal to do that so I never put it
down in policy but I would work it
around so I was like oh you gotta use
the bat okay for sure
you're next but we just got to get
through this activity let me show this
video first I kept saying no we never
[Laughter]
you know we'll talk about that later
yeah you know like yeah do your partner
talk first you know and people were like
excited but kids don't use the restroom
like how many times you have to use the
restroom when you have to go to the
movies but you don't because it's dope
you know I don't want to miss anything
oh I'll go to the restroom justice
[ __ ] chill for a hot second yeah and
then because you know once kids value
their experience they don't want to like
move away from and I think I was
fortunate enough to learn how to like
cultivate that but there was this one
kid was like yo mr. corn I just drink
like two monsters I have to go to the
restaurant okay cause I kept like
stalling and and when I was a teacher we
taught 100 minute blocks those blocked
periods the hell [ __ ] a long [ __ ]
time to be sitting in this guy was he
was like a [ __ ] he had like a lot of
street cred ya know but because he
behaved in class you know that's
actually what helped champion a lot of
like the things that we were able to do
but he asked like four or five times and
was like yo mr. Quan I gotta [ __ ] go
you know and I was like all right but we
were just gonna take care of this
activity first he's like
mmm I love you mr. Quon but I got to do
this need to cut a bottle like one of
the yeah he peed in my class that's
[ __ ] funny yeah and I was like [ __ ]
everybody that was like comical things
but I've also having [ __ ] funny it's
like what this backfired a little bit
yeah and so after that I got called into
the office I got reprimanded like hey
you asked you this many times actually
we pulled we did an informal poll of all
your periods we looked at your restroom
pass and you have like no one uses the
rest we have to write you up because the
parents complaining yeah you know
because we they try to discipline him
and I was like don't worry about it you
have to like no for the Optus optics of
things like we're gonna suspend him I
was like no this one's like on me like
yeah can't suspend him and but the
parents complained and then that's not
like it kind of just unraveled yeah fix
of it that's it's so hard like to figure
out like being the teacher isn't just
like this pamphlet where you do it you
got to figure out a navigate as you go
especially in places like inner-city
schools or charter schools right you
don't know [ __ ] you who's trying to
lie you know right
yeah I mean if you know in that first
situation with the girl who you got
really mad at right like now that with
the knowledge that you have now how
would you done that differently whoa I
wanted the hard rule that I started
making was I don't yell that kids yeah I
can't you know because it's it's it's
triggering its also ineffective and like
I lost the argument as soon as I raise
my voice I'm physically demonstrating
that I cannot convince you guys so I'm
doing something that's just like getting
loud and it's so you know ineffective
that I stop doing it and any time I
would I would like share some of these
things like with my class this is how I
built community I was like this is where
I'm coming from here things that I will
commit to and I'm gonna honor your space
I like value your opinions you're not
like my minions and I'm an authority
figure but I never want you to feel like
I'm an authority figure the authority
figures that you may be used to in your
lives
I'm not your peer right but I want you
to understand that I feel like we are on
even playing fields in this classroom of
Education and learning and and so
something's out what share is like I'm
never gonna yell at you and if you see
me starting to yell
me out on it but yo mr. Guan why are you
yelling you said you're not gonna yell
and then it happened they're like that's
a great check thank you for that let me
calm down a little bit let me thank you
one of my coping mechanisms and it still
is to this day is I get quiet now when
I'm mad because I'm so scared of like
blowing up and my pops pull at me like
you know like that so that's like
something that I learned was I don't
want to be like that you know and and I
start I kind of just get quiet and then
my face gets a little expressionless but
then my wife caught on to this - she
says yeah but you got this like vein
pulsating and I know you're pissed and
you know now that the hairlines receding
like I see it more and more so they
would like point things out like that is
like this come on we know you're pissed
oh I can't get mad I'm not mad I'm not
mad but then it became like and then the
training it you know elevates like will
honor your emotions you know and like
talk about it or like just identify yeah
I am mad acknowledge it can I just get
some space I'm really I'm having a hard
day I'm trying to figure it out and but
when you're real with kids like they're
so real with you and when things like
that happen this want to be respected
yeah and they start modeling what you do
yeah you know I was like I had like some
really some kid who's not would not stop
cussing other classes just be like this
Quan I'm angry right now you know and
then just need a little bit of space and
just give me some time you know that's
like the ideal solution some adult [ __ ]
yeah that is dolt don't even do that
yeah like fury points that if you model
that behavior they're gonna follow it's
so impressionable but then if you model
other things like losing your temper or
you know like trying to exert authority
like I'm the teacher how dare use I will
[ __ ] you I'm the student so how dare you
tell me what to do yeah yeah yeah open
the script on you but yeah so a lot of
these things were like just really cool
moments and they're just other moments
that broke my heart or just got me down
right the only that the only time I
actually got scared and like was fearful
for my safety was I did something where
you you hold kids back this wasn't my
first year almost all my mistakes were
like in my first year but I held the
kids back at the end of the day my sixth
period they're cutting up I was like
that's it you guys got one minute of
silence
that's good 10 minutes 12 minutes all
right I'm counting if you guys don't
shut up you know that kind of thing you
know and and you can't hold kids after
school legally but I did anyway cuz I'm
kind of a rule bender and I just stood
in front of the door and this one kid
just quietly kind of walked up and said
hey uh mr. Quan I have some friends
we're gonna be picking me up today so I
think they're waiting for me it's a new
your best interest in let just let me go
I was like no you know you got to sit
down and then I I like this kid we had a
relationship I say you gotta sit down
everyone's part of the same things I
know but I did all my work and I think
what you're doing is unfair because you
know I've been trying to like turn it
around in your class and he was like
yeah but you know we like we ride
together we're a family and so you got
to sit with everyone and he said okay
well mr. Quan they're waiting for me but
maybe next time they're waiting for you
oh sure yeah and then that like it the
implications of it didn't like register
and I didn't react to it I was like aha
like all right you know it the times not
gonna be that much anyway just have a
seat and he sat down and he was a quiet
kid who had like everyone's respect I
knew he was affiliated or just banging
and he always had like the flossy
esteems and so he had money he was
hustling and no one like physically
challenged him even though he wasn't
like very physically imposing like this
guy's scary and I knew that but then for
it to like actually actualize herself
because I took something away from him
was a scary moment it was a scary moment
and that's the only time that I was ever
fearful of anything and he actually
didn't make it he cuz I keep tabs on
like a lot of the students who I had
relationships with he got locked up for
a pretty hefty crime so I wrote to him
but then I think he he didn't want to
interact because his cousin was a little
bit younger here's my school and he was
just like no he's not responding to any
of us so he's like just in a really dark
place but he had that kind of like
internal strength to do that to a
teacher like to make an over or covert
whatever you want to call it threat like
that but very low-key but it's like a
cerebral attack what is it like that
that's when I get scared like cuz you
know the threat is real yeah you know he
doesn't
to like yell and shout and pound this
chest it's like I'm letting you know
yeah and get some work done on like the
I forget if it's like the next day or
was a Friday whatever it was in the time
sequence but I remember talking to I
trying to talk to him afterwards about
it he said I know what you're talking
about yeah we're still cool like you're
my favorite class and you still I still
want to like improve and all that but
that was scary
yeah there's like there's no boundaries
for this kid
yeah that level of like cuz I'm you're
cool but don't cross me yeah yeah that's
some thug [ __ ] dude dad that's a
straight-up thug [ __ ] and and and it's
unfortunate that you know he ended up
getting locked up but then that begs the
question right and in a lot of these
poor communities right and when Nikki
Lurie was here I asked him how much do
you think racism plays a role in the
criminal justice system and he said a
hundred percent yeah yeah right and then
so when you look at the people who are
incarcerated right there tends to be a
pretty clear trend poor in black right
porn brown right so then how big of a
role does education play and how
important is it in in you know kids kids
who are in those type of communities
right to cut to keep them out of the
prison system ya know and it's a great
question that I've really thought about
over the last couple years at least in
my latest education or like learning but
I think school has such a critical role
with like not only educators teachers in
the classroom counselors school
psychologists you know the campus
security I'm talking about everyone who
works in education is an educator you
know it cuz you have some sphere of
influence over kids I think there
there's such a crucial role in that but
I think it's it's almost it's so obvious
to talk about that I think it begs the
question and you have to bring into the
conversation of oK we've asked schools
to do more and more and more with less
and less yeah right less funding now
right less access to trainings you got
to do more days you know of instruction
you just got to do more and more and
more we have families who are becoming
dual income earners
at the you know best-case-scenario
that's increasing the same family home
of one parent working making a livable
wage is like laughable now you know and
so okay we're asking schools to do all
this and now teachers are counselors now
they're you know not only guidance and
like emotional counselors but like guide
like college counselors too now they're
nurses you're asking them to do all
these different things where's the
funding to bring that back into the
classrooms you know like yeah so let's
move some funds even at the local level
or at the state level let's move some
funds away from some other areas and
bring it back into education is I think
important to consider that other
lobbyists and other groups aren't
willing to talk about because they think
well that's their job they're supposed
to do you know it's like yeah but times
are different now and you're what
they're saying do it on as little money
as possible like we I mean that
indirectly shows you how much importance
they play like they'll talk about it for
again for optics you have politicians
talking about how important education is
to this country how important it is to
build and develop the future of the you
know the country in the world but then
what are you actually doing you to bait
up to back that up
action I wonder why education is so I
mean in from a monetary sense why so
devalued in this country just because
it's like a such a huge foundation a
huge factor to how our young leaders are
going to progress right like I I never
truly [ __ ] understood that [ __ ] just
because I mean it's it's sad to say but
you know teachers are babysitters really
when mom and dad are gone the teachers
are there all the time they're the one
that has to watch them like you said
they have to see it like number one like
checking out their clothes if they're
getting enough food all those others
there's so many factors to being a
teacher right that really affects this
young mind I never understood why this
country devalues our our educators so
much like you almost like that's what
you're supposed to do kind of stuff you
know what I mean
and it's it's more important that I
think if anything else we want to talk
about like defunding the police or
whatever whatnot we'll take some of that
[ __ ] money and put it into education
that's I think what's on the table yes
these type of this guy yeah because
let's let's go at it at the root of the
problem let's start with the source
let's fix them here before they become
like these are
dalts right and i preventive instead of
reactive
right yes exact and I really really do
like after-school programs I think help
I mean for me I didn't really go I had a
go work in my parents store yeah but I
know like after-school programs helped a
lot of people out specifically kids and
sports yeah and I think statistically
studies will back that up too right and
100% yeah 100% yeah and I think the
impact an individual teacher or you know
you could even expand that to a group of
teachers or to all teachers that can
have on like individual lives and it's
it's so important for individuals but I
think when you're looking at like
widespread change like you guys are
talking about it has to start at systems
yeah I think part of that is yeah
there's the federal government but a lot
of education because every demographic
every region is so you know it's
different the one size fit all you know
model dress exactly yeah
and so then you look at like local
politicians like what are like the you
know the the bills that they're
supporting what are like the changes
that they're advocating for but
everyone's eyes away from education
because it's so [ __ ] complicated mmm
it there's no there's no monetary gains
for me yeah only talked about it yeah
I'll talk but we need to reform them but
they'll give you like the same sounds
like exactly 20 years ago was like
smaller class sizes you know higher paid
teachers yeah or yeah more money in
education more money for after-school
programs yes you know and for
individuals who may not have even really
thought about education yeah 20 years
yeah the fact that it's in your brains
is that it's probably you know they just
become a checkbox to these people like
in order to make sure I have the basics
covered this is what I need to check off
correct yeah when I went to when I
wanted to be a teacher right it was
obviously because of educators that I've
been in high school that they affected
my life I was like okay so I want to do
this too and you know my dad talked
about pay it can't be that [ __ ] bad
but it was like in the ECD USD it was
like 28 K I was like what I'm gonna have
to suck dick for a living like 28,000
and they're like oh yeah that's your
first other was it go up to it's like 32
I was like I can't live off of that how
the [ __ ] am I supposed to live off of
this [ __ ] you know what I mean and it's
so sad that the determining factor for
me for not to become an educator was
because of a salary you know
I mean you got a you know in order to
endear that low of a salary you really
got to have the passion behind it then
and you know what it would think but but
it's also fair to say like alright you
know what if I get paid that much I
can't do this yeah I mean at least
you're being honest about it and not
being irresponsible like well [ __ ] I
can't find any other job so I'll just
take this on for now no then you're not
you're not going into that with the
responsibility that you that you're
supposed to actually care about yeah and
think about now I'm like starting to
wonder how bad of a teacher disrespect
me and I just like really quiet I'm
never gonna yell at you above but the
funny thing is like after school I'm
getting a bunch of my homies do not even
know it's me I have a [ __ ] mask on
you the next day I'm like what happened
what happened so who beat you up in the
parking lot like who was that it was me
there have been more instances that
would like to count you know remember
where it's because a teacher physically
like did something to it oh wow oh man
yeah whether there's some of them just
crack me up because even in like the
reprimand like the teacher knows they
[ __ ] up there's like Quan I just want
to get fired can you just make your
voice like I know I [ __ ] up big can
you help me out here it's like what did
you do it's like I threw him through a
window it's like I don't know how you're
gonna work around this whether it's a
shove or like pinching their neck or
grabbing their head and like what the
book does that you know like things that
it's just like because you just get so
frustrated so you react what's your
condition to and it doesn't remove the
behavior but you identify that behavior
and you think oh can we prevent this
let's target the behavior not the person
but I mean like therapy or some [ __ ] cuz
there's so much to specially inner-city
schools like that's what we're talking
about right he was telling me like in
the beginning that some of his female
you know co-workers would be getting
therapy because they they were you know
like not sexually abused but uh harassed
yeah yes right yeah verbally harassed
you know a lot of Marano and you end
those improper
you know comments on the way they look
right so there are people who get like
mentally damaged from from just trying
to be an educator yeah and then I think
districts and charter organizations they
started smartening up I think you know
on a moral standpoint just to prevent
this from happening and making it better
but also from a financial standpoint cuz
they're one lawsuit away from being sued
you know a teacher says oh a student ABC
said this may be the stereotype is a
student the teacher has issues with
class classroom management maybe they're
new in their career so it gets kind of
dismissed or swept under the rug
teacher starts documenting it they
lawyer up you say this happened there's
actual evidence of video footage holding
like a year-long case yeah boom that's
like a million dollar lawsuit plus you
know but yeah it's complicated so like
for you what do you think it was that
really guided you and helped you to
persevere like those beginning years
probably when it's the hardest not to
say that it got easy now I'm still I'm
sure there's still a lot of challenges
and that's my second question like what
do you see as the biggest challenges in
like inner-city schools or in charter
schools that are in inner-city
neighborhoods yeah I think to that first
question it's 100% of my wife right she
is my rock and when I started my
teaching career she was there you were
there when I first started dating her
but um one thing that kind of like
started off our conversation was I'm
sure saying oh I wanted to be a teacher
you know and I'm not gonna go down that
route but do you need help like setting
up your classroom it was like my first
year and I was like all right [ __ ] none
of my other significant others offered
even to help you know and we weren't
even dating at the time we're just you
know uh not friends well cuz wife is our
homies little sister I realize I just
don't
you know nothing like the start of our
relationship was not on very you know
like noble terms you know I [ __ ] over
I didn't [ __ ] oh I I'm dating my one of
my closest homies younger sister and
they yeah when I started catching
feelings for her you know I went to him
I was like yo you know like there may be
something that's kind of like budding
with your sister me as I [ __ ] that
you're not doing it man like that's just
not gonna happen and and I think he's a
pretty aggressive fellow but then he
ended up saying like please just don't
yeah it just makes things complicated
you know and the the additional context
is that he we had two mutual friends who
did the same thing and he actually gave
permission but I think that's why yes
was forever tainted and he was like yo I
like two other friendships are like
changed I don't want that to happen and
and I said [ __ ] that scenario if it
worked out but I don't even know how we
started talking about how did that trap
because she said she was the inspiration
oh yeah
she was my bedrock and so who like I I
never really complained about teaching
or the things that I was like really
struggling with with you know my peers
definitely not like my I don't have a
great relationship with my parents you
know but it was it was my wife and she
was always there so having a good
support system is I think critical and
then I think for some demographics like
going into the teaching field for
financial reasons it's like a failure
you know there's even like the like
comical video clip that starts off with
saying I oh ha ha ha you couldn't do it
so you decided to teach or something
right yeah yeah yeah and um yeah but
that wasn't the case for me like my
parents were incredibly proud that I
cannot believe that you decided to be a
teacher
ha ha cut not my parents yeah you sure
you'd want to be a lawyer I think you're
what
criminal-defense my could be exacting my
dad so I was like I want to be a teacher
he goes cool so you want to be poor yeah
that's exactly what he said you want to
be a tailor as I bow so fast
yeah the value of his education is like
sacred in my family and so that was
really cool to have and then a lot of my
friends a lot of them who were making a
lot more money than I was would still be
like we would be out at yo we'd be at
like bars in k-town and then one of like
the when we're trying to like just meet
girls or just you know have fun if I go
and this is all man dude you gotta meet
mr. Quan he's a teacher and he does all
these things and I was like yo was that
kind of like a play just like an in to
get in his like not - [ __ ] dope that
you're like having that support system
was instrumental but other things was
extending that support system into the
school and so I had a lot of like
like-minded peers who are still a really
close group of friends and we still meet
up we're all in different like some even
moved out of education but we're like
our education our teacher homies mmm
we're still connected we have like a
chat and all that but I think what helps
is the ongoing training that I received
it was not only like okay you got to be
hopeful you know it's not lip service
it's like you got to be hopeful because
here's the training that we provided you
not do it and we're so excited to see
what you're gonna do with it
so I always had a lot of like champions
and like cheerleaders next to me and I
had a lot of mentors I'm of the type you
know like if if I'm not good at
something but I see someone doing it
really well I have no shame in saying
like of course that you know that she
was sick how'd you do it
yeah like can I talk to you can I buy
you a cup of coffee can I sit down with
you or can I go with your approach let
me break it down to like a granular
level because I thought some people were
saying like oh the art of teaching I was
like no because I'm going into like you
know a handful of teachers classes and
I'm seeing something similar I just
can't I don't know how to label it and
then I started like really reaching out
for mentors who I still keep in touch
with when I have issues now or problems
I can't solve I'll reach out to like my
support network and my mentors and it
just it just keeps you going because it
really takes a village you know and I
took that to heart and so these are
things that I would share with my
students and say and when you can't
figure out that problem or you're
struggling with that essay that
why I'm asking you to create this group
you know of your peers share your
numbers right now like nah like mr. Quon
le like hey hey I don't want to talk to
this serious are you from our families
get along the conversation that you
gotta have right yeah like what what
street you want yeah no yeah so things
like that is just like really when you
when you have experiences like that I
feel very fortunate because a lot of
those things I couldn't control is just
I was fortunate that these people were
available you know because I've had on
instances but even in my current role
right now where I reached out to
someone's like hey how did you do that
can I figure that out or you know I
really like that I want to mimic it cuz
that's something that I think I could I
could do and you know I want to work
with you more on then they're just
elusive yeah it's just like mmm you got
to wait a little bit young buck I don't
know how many years you had in this yeah
I'm like yeah this is my first year you
know it's my fifth year it's hard
sometimes though cause like when I see
other people they ask me for advice in
their career path I like oh I want to do
like comedy and I tell them that Bridal
know oh I wish I could tell you
something right cuz I'm trying to figure
it so it's hard sometimes right because
sometimes when they see like okay well
how did you do this and I'm like I don't
[ __ ] know like I've never had the
time to stop and think how right and I
just did and so like because it
constantly evolved and changed so I
guess I guess kind of see like maybe
sometimes it's hard for people it's like
ha it's like okay well if somebody asked
me well how do you do YouTube I would
tell them you [ __ ] do a video and you
upload the specifics I [ __ ] know yeah
I was like just I don't know be
passionate about something and commit to
it but you know sometimes people want
specifics about stuff and as I know she
I don't think I've even thought about
the specifics yeah and you can't hold
anyone against it whether whatever
whatever is going on in their life their
life situation or just the desire to to
mentor or like yeah I'm sure if you
don't have it that doesn't mean you're a
sucky person
not to mention some not everybody can be
Mentors yeah right yeah or even like you
know you may disagree
because of the Sacramento Queens Jersey
but Laker oh he was not aureus for not
being a mentor in the beginning portion
of yeah this career yeah he's I figure
this [ __ ] out watch me yeah and he was
the worst teacher ever just let you know
nobody ever [ __ ] like I love I have
Kobe right there I [ __ ] love them but
you know just to let you know P it's
behind Lakers got a help like dirty
referees just to put that out there damn
well know it as far as like challenges
go then you know what do you think is
like a pretty glaring challenge in the
environment that you're in
yeah I think like we we can you know
talk our ears off about the system yeah
and then we could also talk about like
individual performances but I think
David you brought it up is I don't think
our society values education
holistically yeah for sure you know and
I don't know I don't have an answer to
that I'm sure viewers will have some
opinions is it social media is it like
you know the lure of money is it the
education system is broken and you could
succeed in other routes 100% you know
and I think that's a fact but that's
that's such a small minority of people
well and I would even venture to say
that but it's a large enough population
where you can't just disregard it you
know it's like well you know I'm gonna
win the lottery well I'm gonna disregard
that because you had one in 300 like
high school dropouts who want to go on
to be super successful yeah you know
what very small someone actually
questioned me on that it's like eight
like John you're you seem pretty
motivated like what was your
demographics like where'd you grow I was
like uh you know I grew up in like
Cerritos I went to Whitney's like
[ __ ] Whitney or like [ __ ] knee cuz
they came from like Norway yeah nobody
and say you were a [ __ ] dweeb I'm
sure you had like all the access that
you had and I was like like what are you
like all your friends doing and I
thought back and I think there's a
certain percentage of our close group of
friends who weren't successful well they
took an alternative route or they didn't
go the traditional
okay succeed in high school go to
college two-year or four-year find a
career make my in advance you know
that's just like the cookie cutter way
but they found alternative means or if
you look at their success story they
overcame obstacles that other kids see
in like other disadvantaged societies
but somehow they made it and they didn't
ya know they they beat the statistics
mm-hmm iemon can be inspiring
yeah and it's inspiring so I think I
mean I think it's just sometimes because
these kids watch like you know these
young YouTube kids and they're like yeah
well I was like but do you realize how
many people are on YouTube like they're
like literally like a billion people are
on YouTube and only yeah half of a half
of a half of a half a percent right
living off yeah yeah so it's like your
chances are not not great it's great for
you to kind of leverage it and go
somewhere else maybe but but the thing
is it's like like for example they go
well you didn't graduate college right I
was like yeah but I was in that
[ __ ] over five years but a lot
of the stuff that I'm great at the only
reason why I figured out that I can do
this what was because I had those
experiences yeah period in a story like
where the [ __ ] do you think I learned
how to read and [ __ ] write it was
real cool like the reason why I could
speak the way that I do was because of
the education that I had though it
doesn't it does it goes hand in hand you
you have to give yourself that upper
hand first before you go ahead and
figure out that you could throw it away
these there are so many learning skill
that's why I like I like I know i'ma
have to go ask my fiancee about the poem
when we have kids right I want them to
go to a public school mmm
really bad yeah it's a bigger pool of
people that's life you know I don't want
I don't want to be able to pick and
choose everybody that they get to be a
lot I want them to be able to navigate
through life how you're supposed to yeah
right and so that's like the the promise
of what an education can give you
whether you choose to be a doctor or you
figure out what your specific Lane is
through your major at least it'll give
you options to figure out why right and
I think a lot of people eliminate these
things and they don't figure out their
why first before they just toss it away
that's why I like you know that first
year of college they're so set on what
they're going to be I say yo breathe
give it a go try your best and figure it
out because what happens to a lot of
people like it did some of the people I
know they're like I'm gonna be a doctor
they say that from the day one and they
went through all this [ __ ] education
that made four years and then like [ __ ]
I didn't want to be this yeah and I
didn't you what - cuz we're friends I
was like I know you could
do the shits you [ __ ] dumbass you
gonna be a doctor
you know I'm it's like you know what
their skills are but they just chosen to
ignore it and they just kind of went
that path so a lot of this stuff too
like an education is very important like
about well what you're saying actually
just reminds me to that even with an
education you get priced out not only is
there a lack of funding but to go to
like these major universities right
there's there's a pay-to-play model and
and the most ironic thing about that is
it the core foundation right they don't
get enough funding but the ones who
aren't gonna make it to to go on to
those universities even if they have an
opportunity to might not be able to
afford it yeah or maybe they might get
grants and scholarships and all that
living expenses right maybe it's out of
state you know so you just get priced
out and so that's like the ironic thing
if it's colleges make [ __ ] major
co-op right yeah I'm sure they got major
[ __ ] Gua and the endowment funds that
the private universities have billions
you know maybe
okay maybe not billions but triple-digit
millions you know some of these put like
USC I know for sure got that have money
billions I'm guessing right and their
endowment fund so these institutions
make major guap but it's like how do you
even get there though no you gotta start
at the basics you know I'm like the
specific numbers but the cost of higher
education has like yeah drastically
increased ridiculous yeah well hey
hasn't increased that yeah not the whole
boomer argument of like you know back in
my day like it costs this much so yeah
well that's why people can't [ __ ] go
to college now yeah because of your ass
making the policy yeah yeah like I fed
for kids where 250k job yeah and bought
a bow in a house
well houses yeah yeah doesn't mean I
think that I mean education is just so
[ __ ] expensive like I wish host yeah
yeah
does the Community College route seems
to be the way for a lot of people I
think is a very smart thing to do
Community College and EEMA state
universities are a lot more affordable
because I went to UCR and I went to Saks
day now surprised how cheap cheaper you
know the state university level was I
was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it's night
and day
yeah
within California Cal State versus a UC
already pick different in same how it
was like 20 I was like close to 20 G's
to attend a university per year and then
at the state level it was like 8,000 or
7,000 and even before and at that time
that was a price hike because before
that it was about four right so I was
like it's ridiculous like in my mind
it's like if you can if money is a issue
go to a state university yeah it's like
what one of the homies shared in our
like chat thread the predicted like our
anticipated cost of UCLA in like 18
years or 20 years like when you're kids
entering college if the rate of tuition
keeps climbing at this rate and it was
[ __ ] ridiculous like 45 K or like 50
ka years okay you suck a dick dude I
mean even even for like the average you
know income families that's not an easy
thing to swing you know yeah and then
that's like then you get into this cycle
this perpetual cycle of debt that is a
huge problem in this country right
because you're putting a price on
education yeah and so like again going
back to just the lip service of talking
about the importance of education right
but no real action behind it no real
funding behind it nothing fundamentally
had fundamentally changing right and
then so that already sets you up so okay
let's say you get to the university
level now you're coming out of your
college career with a debt right and
that debt could range anywhere from like
10k to maybe like 20 30 40 K and then
you decide to go post-grad right then
your debt goes up to six figures now and
then so like from there you got to get a
job now that's gonna realistically help
you pay that loan off quicker but you're
already starting behind and so the like
that's the backwards thing is like
they're putting a price to pay for you
to get educated yeah and that's that's
the biggest issue here is like not just
the funding that's necessary at you know
Elementary School's junior high schools
and high schools but even if you're able
to get past all that can you afford a
college education can you afford a post
would you guys be okay if your kid came
up to you
I was like I'm not gonna go to college
like this is what I'm doing yeah I cuz I
can't knock that cuz like I mean I
dropped out yeah you know so for me it's
like what is it that you want to do
because the thing is if it's just oh I
don't want to study and I don't like
school any more than not you're asked to
staying in school if you have a
legitimate reason though like you have a
passion for something I'm hoping my kid
doesn't want to go to college that's
expected College I'm like boy right
there if he's like I really want to go
to college I'm like you're my least
favorite child get the [ __ ] out pop lock
it up no just so expensive yeah I think
in America or in you know in the United
States the education is like the great
equalizer people have that opportunity
in some countries you know halfway
across the world there's a caste system
or you don't have that chance you
wherever you're born don't look at the
drug that's where you're gonna be yeah
yeah are you kidding me yeah yeah you
know and I think that's pretty cool but
like you guys are saying the cost of
education just is so ridiculous do your
poor nada I wouldn't be mad if my kid
said I'm not going to college and like
you're sad say okay what's the plan then
let's map this out yeah you're sick of
this teacher or you're just
disenfranchise you don't like learning
whatever the [ __ ] all right I support
you but know this once you're 18 I'm not
supporting you anymore so you better
have a [ __ ] plan yeah whatever it is
is okay
[ __ ] i'ma go to trade school and okay
let's look at those like salaries let's
look at what you need a livable income
to live in the areas that you want or
the lifestyle that you want I think if
you start backwards planning a little
bit like that to bring some perspective
it should be helpful because I know my
parents did do didn't do that kind of
planning with me they only a.m. they
didn't know how right they didn't have
that kind of knowledge yeah they just
knew that okay you get these high
professions you're gonna be happy
education is important because they come
from a country that prioritizes it you
know it's like you better study or i'ma
beat your ass yeah do I really value
education that if you're doing that so I
value not getting to a slope and that's
well the generation has a different
problem than us right like this
generation has like a burden of choice
you guys have a lot of [ __ ] options
and I always say this is like it's
almost arguably harder for you now
because before it's like like you know
we were talking about how when your
basic needs aren't meant those are the
things that are prioritized right it's
like I need to fill this because I need
this well now in this other generation
that we're seeing that they're not
growing up as poor as us you know so
they're they're their options are huge
and so they're they're kind of
overwhelmed like they're sitting there
and now because they have so many
choices paralysis of choice exactly they
sit there and they don't do anything at
all because now there's second-guessing
everything is like well if I go into
this route what if I want to do this and
what if I want to do that like our
parents didn't have that it was more
like okay I need money I need to feed my
family no matter what I do this is where
the ends meat is and this is what I need
to meet now it's like that's not even an
option they don't even give a [ __ ]
they're like well well I'll figure that
[ __ ] out you know I have a roof over my
mom and dad are paying for stuff now
it's like what do I want to be that to
them they just don't do anything now
that's that's the thing that I like I
I'm trying to get some of life young
listeners to understand is that you keep
saying that number one it's like you
don't know what to do is like no you
know what you want to do you just have
too many options that's the difference
and you're scared that you're wasting
your time by choosing one route and I
keep telling people you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're gonna be until you try
that's what it is I didn't know I was
gonna do a [ __ ] podcast yeah I didn't
think of that [ __ ] I thought I was gonna
be when I first started in the space I
assumed that I was gonna be the biggest
stand-up comic in the world I did that
[ __ ] for 67 known for a long time and I
was like I don't really enjoy this that
much I don't enjoy doing stand-up as
much as I used to so what I do I
switched over I did YouTube instead
YouTube was fun not like this is great
now I want to do food okay well food is
fun too now I want to do a podcast
things change your your options change
constantly like you don't know what you
want until you actually try it but
inactivity doesn't doesn't grow anything
yeah yeah literally it has nothing you
can't you can't let it die inside of
your mind you know you have to take that
first step you have to take action and
then figure out it because there's no
perfect plan you know like you could
plan as much as you want it's never
gonna go according oh yeah and I think
that's something that you know younger
people will learn as they get older just
like we did right we always thought we
knew better when we were young
you know like our parents would say
something like nah [ __ ] that I know
better
yeah but then you learn through your
mistakes but the most important thing is
that you do you commit to something and
you take action doesn't mean that you
have to stick to it for the rest of your
life yeah but there's no other way that
you're gonna find out whether or not
that's your lane and even from dad
justjust from the process of you
evolving as a human being
my other path it might go into another
path right and might diverge from there
so who knows but if you don't do
anything and you stay inactive and
you're thinking like what should i do
what should I do
that's exactly what's gonna happen are
you just gonna sit there and think what
should I do that's it yeah and that's
the extent of it well that wraps up this
podcast that was [ __ ] educational
that's really great [ __ ] out of
yourself out with that lots of piece of
information
nice little knock on your door from her
older brother well do you have anything
you want to plug no man he's just an
educator yeah just doing the good doing
the good bTW the cookie business on the
side if there was anything you'd be like
I think this be Allah it's something
I've been thinking about and I talked
about with my wife with the BLM movement
which isn't old it's in and the things
that they're talking about it's also
like decades okay civil rights movement
yeah yeah you know and I think we
challenged ourselves be like what are we
going to do to change our behaviors what
are we gonna commit to doing and acting
and traditionally it's always been time
or money right you're gonna act and like
get involved or do something are you
gonna join a group or you're gonna you
know be do something productive or
you're gonna donate and I think it's
it's we also want to learn we added a
third element to that we want to learn
more yes we looked at literature we're
starting to follow the the channels that
really that we aligned to that we think
they are talking to right talk that are
really smart and intelligent and I would
really challenge everyone out there to
do more than just like what is going on
that's a good space you gotta be in you
know but and then what so act
I think acting is important for sure for
sure and then I kind of touched upon
that too on a post I recently made
was that don't let anybody define what
doing enough is but do something right
and then and start your path on your own
like no no one could tell you you got to
go from zero to 100 and if you're not
doing that you're a piece of [ __ ]
everybody's gonna have their process
with this but the most important thing
just like we were talking about in terms
of career or or figuring on what your
path is is to start take that first step
whatever that first step may be and then
from there you'll figure out along the
way you're right about why part's really
important yeah to me is the most
important part and I think I got a
little bit of backlash cuz I've been not
very vocal yeah one of the biggest thing
I've been vocal about it's just you know
that black scream you know and yes and
people were like you're very why aren't
you impressed with that I was like I see
I've seen this cuz I grew up in a very
predominately black area I've seen this
type of activism activism I've seen it
so [ __ ] often I'm almost sick of it
because it's like none of you are
questioning why you are the way that you
are you are just doing it just to do it
and I was like this is a cyclical issue
don't I I I'm not here to police
people's activity in activism right I'm
personally don't think I'm an activist
I'm just very passionate about this
stuff because I've seen this [ __ ] my
whole life so that why part is very
[ __ ] important right because now we
have this issue of we do things for
social currency right we do it just
because other people are doing it we've
seen this already we saw two years ago
with the death of falando caste I seen
this already multiple times near if I
have to go through this again I'm gonna
be a looter next time I think I'm gonna
do that right my patience is running
[ __ ] thin right I've went to a
protest I went to a vigil next time I
have to go through this again in ten
years I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] up that's the
point that I am so I understand this
this is this is why I'm saying that why
like you mentioned is very [ __ ]
important that interest rope an
introspective part why do you have anti
black thoughts why is it that I think
this way and it doesn't have to be
illicit it doesn't have to be so in your
[ __ ] face but then especially in the
eighth and I'm finding out the most
which I didn't know was in the Asian
community how even in like churches I
mean there's a place of God when we see
a lot of anti blackness yeah yeah that's
it's it's sadly you know pretty
ingrained in a lot of Asian culture you
know in the Asian countries even just
like Asian countries where we see a
darker skinned person of our own culture
well we think it's terrible
this to the point where [ __ ] people
in Korea looked like see-through yes I
can see the veins in your body yeah you
know it just kind of became the thing of
like darker skin tone is inferior in
some way I mean I had a lot to do with
the the working class and that you know
royalty was right right yeah yeah and I
think David what we've you know socially
interacted more than a handful of times
mainly through Edie and I think I want
to put it out there that I'm admiring
what you're doing I respect it and I
think if it hasn't been said before it
is [ __ ] ballsy to do so because it
takes courage to do what you're doing
with your platform and the base that you
developed and my like knowledge of
social media and all that's you know not
that great but I do know what marketing
and branding and all that is and I think
what you're doing is you're you like
you're saying it's probably started with
your why and you what you wanted to
enact some change and I don't want to
see the same [ __ ] at the same time
you may be alienating some of your base
or your population or sure yeah and that
you're like you know what I don't give a
[ __ ] like outside of a monetary
perspective from a principle standpoint
I don't give a [ __ ] because this is
where I stand
yeah you know and whether they walk away
you know for those of you who view this
or if you disagree with anything that
David says I really think diversity
makes us better absolutely you know and
if you I've actually started following
like all trite and extreme because I got
a donor supposed to yeah I know yeah
it's not like at first is that well I'm
gonna count this [ __ ] like it's
such a [ __ ] myopic narrow viewpoint
of where I'm trying to win as opposed to
like let me just understand where
they're coming from and where do we see
eye to eye like okay where do we
disagree like can we get better and
learn and I think that's why what you're
doing is just I don't see it too often
you know especially in the Asian
community so it's really yeah I mean you
know when I first started doing this
stuff to like I didn't realize like how
much of oddball it was like oh people
just speak their [ __ ] mind you say
whatever yeah and then I'm also the
weird thing is I think like the theme
that I'm finding
- is that I always talked about this
recently where it's there's racism head
is a spectrum you know and that's what
we're really finding out they people
think that they're not racist because
they're not going out calling people the
n-word wrong people change people or
just you know prejudice not calm people
you know the f-word yeah I forgot they
say and that we're finding out that it's
a spectrum it's it's really deep into
your ideals and what you think of these
individuals as people right and I'm
learning that right now right I'm
learning it the most in in Asian people
when I see these people come out the
woodwork especially that's why I like
this movement so much right now because
it's forcing people to have an opinion
you you want to stay in the middle line
as much as you want but now you're you
have the choice where you can and like I
said this to somebody who I just had a
conversation with he goes I want to be
on that middle side cuz I could see both
sides I'm like what's the other side
what's the other side of racism right
and he didn't have an answer I was like
that's why you're not allowed to be in
the middle because if you're gonna have
a stance if your stance is in the middle
what is your mission statement mm-hm you
don't have one so now you have to choose
that's why you're uncomfortable it's
because you don't know why you have anti
black sentiments you know you don't hate
black people but you know you feel these
bad things and you don't want to talk
about it that's what I'm trying to
expose right now that's why I like for
me people like they sent me this thing
of it wasn't Iggy Azalea it was [ __ ]
I think it was a Lia bang she's crazy
right she says a lot of like anti black
things and they go you should talk about
this it's like not my position that's
somebody in black culture will let will
let them police their own I got to do my
with my community I got to work with
mine first that's why I'm adding a lot
of these Korean rappers the [ __ ]
trash yes you know I mean like that kid
Owen you're [ __ ] hot garbage I told
them if I see you I will slap you on
[ __ ] site and the reason why was
somebody like that throw or break your
phone yeah I'm not gonna break my phone
he ain't [ __ ] worth the boss slap the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of the kid and for me
and I always talk about this - I'm very
very highly perceptive of Who I am now
as an adult and I Know Who I am is
because of two specific cultures my
Korean upbringing I wasn't born in this
country and then my also the the the
black American hip-hop
that is that's kind of molded Who I am
for me to not give credits that and to
not denounce that makes me a [ __ ]
Chauncy ass [ __ ] yeah so I refuse to be
that person and if you're that person to
where you took from this culture and
they're just asking like yo can you back
me up they're asking you know and then
you go none of my business
[ __ ] you yeah yeah that's what I have an
issue with yeah it's it's it's it's like
um it's very it's definitely is
cowardice and and pathetic but I think
also to to note is that sometimes these
people just have that disconnect in that
fundamental thought of recognizing that
I'm taking from this culture they just
think it's just status quo you know they
don't really take it a step further of
actually recognizing that's black
culture and that's ingrained in your
life they're just thinking it's just
culture like it's not black culture
that's pop culture but yes it's a pop
culture but it came from black culture
right it got popularized into pop
culture but it's that's not the origin
you know it came from something that's
what I'm saying some people don't take
that next step
mm-hmm and they don't recognize that so
they're just thinking what am I doing
wrong
like why are people attacking me because
I like hip-hop music or yeah I like the
way to buy certain brands or or taco
certain because they don't and so
ignorant is always the biggest problem
there are inherent racists for sure like
who are on the extreme end of that
spectrum that you're talking about but
then there are the ones I feel like kind
of in-between where it's more of
ignorant than racism right rather than
being on the low end of racism you're
kind of on the high end of ignorance of
like not recognizing yeah you got to
understand that's your taking from that
and that's why people are calling to you
the compassionate side I am fire and
it's hard for me it's like because I'd
done that route yeah yeah and now I'm on
the fed-up side I know I know it so and
I think both are equally effective right
it depends on who you're talking to who
has like
open-minded I think some people don't
and that's where I come in with the
fists of fury they're like and then what
I want to do is like if you made a
profit off of this right and then you're
sitting there and you're mocking this
movement I'll make sure you don't make a
[ __ ] sinking single cent and then
you'll see how much this culture has
affected your lifestyle there's other
kid dude wasn't Owen but I forgot his
[ __ ] name he's a [ __ ] too chic and
this ride a little too chic [ __ ]
you know he bro he goes he wrote it was
a New Wave mattered which is his uep
that drop and I don't really care about
the social aspect of a BLM I just want I
just want you guys to check out my album
how [ __ ] socially irresponsible is
that yeah blame them and this kid just
wrote back he just wrote comedian to me
and I was like you probably only speak
English then I wrote clown right back to
him yeah and I also told him if I see
you I'll [ __ ] but everybody has a
different route and may God be with you
[Laughter]
and Jesus is the way but Jesus Christ
and then I wash it all up you're stingy
obviously some nice well guys you guys
can catch the genius brain podcast on
every audio platform out there you guys
know we're here every Thursday and
Sundays you know entertain you on your
your commute or whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing number one podcast everybody else
sucks
[Laughter]